What?
You gonna pick me up?
Wait, how do you do that?
Wait, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa!
We're like cheerleaders or something.
Oh, you're awesome!
Whoa!
Sorry, going...
The story of...
Who did I just nearly drown, Phoebe?
My fault.
Can you drown in this?
Oh, God.
I don't know.
goes crazy oh there's clothes do you guys want to like get
some new clothes there's there's clothes over here there's
clothes oh my how do I get up here oh my oh Very cool.
Wait, I was kind of like these.
How do I put them on?
Oh, I see.
Oh, how do you do?
You're okay in there?
Oh, wait, you have a drink.
Just in the water.
She's just doing that.
That's her special skill.
It's my cap.
This is my cap.
Hi, everybody.
Oh, if you already have hats on.
How do you, oh my gosh, how do you do that?
Yo.
Wow!
Oh, now we all have different hats!
Yeah!
Nice glasses.
Thank you, nice hat.
You look like Cartman from...
You look like Steiner.
Free Steiner's ready to go.
That's us!
That's us, baby.
Wait, now, now, now I've got to talk with a British guy.
accent but it can't be too british because he uh he's a he's
an america boo and so he's lost a little bit of his accent
not not the america no that's true though he has well well i
mean i thought i have two to be honest oh my gosh stiner
catching strays well he didn't answer our dms before stream
so that's his fault well this looks lovely guys like
genuinely i want to i want to go here right now i think that
is it i don't know anything about this game do you guys know
anything no actually no just that people like it that's it
yeah i don't know um we should go on a little camping trip
like this sometime this is nice yeah yeah wait why is it
suffering it comes as you to camp we'll become you to camp
apparently yes Wait, I also want to ask chat, how is the
volume for everybody?
Because I'm using tilt controls, so I need...
You guys tell me.
I'm using tilt controls.
I'm using tilt controls!
I love when people just spam that in the lobby.
I'm using tilt controls.
It's good?
Okay!
The sound is crazy in the water.
You guys look.
I know, right?
Oh, wow.
they can draw hello are you in the water make my voice even
deeper hello hello hello wait i can't oh there it is oh
hello hello i'm in the water hello i'm in the water but
everybody only is out only everybody only hears me sound
normal the hard way yeah me too honestly like swimming in a
mountain lake like this is like my favorite thing i just
want to starfish in the water yeah oh i'm drowning oh there
we go so that's what i like to do is like just starfish wow
this is so nice wow oh wow wow wow i do Wait, how'd I get
all the way over here?
Oh my god.
Wow, great swimming, guys.
I like how it's just running in the water.
Beach ball!
Coldplay!
And then you're talking to me.
Oh.
What did I just do?
Okay, pick up.
I got it in midair.
Sick tricks.
Oh, dang it.
Whoa, that was pretty good.
Was it?
Oh, for me, sure.
Oh, so close.
Oh, I thought I got it.
You guys, we're litterer.
Oh, wait, there's something here.
There's a to-do list.
We have to do something?
Oh, we know just camping?
We have to set up camp, light a campfire.
Yeah.
Make a bigger fire than last year.
Catch at least one fish for dinner.
Hey!
Wake up early for the sunrise.
Go on a hike.
Befriend wild animals, but they're not friendly.
Oh, we gotta go.
Wait, you guys, our camping trip is over.
Over.
Are you okay?
Oh, wait, we did it all.
Oh, you're dead.
What happened?
Oh, what happened?
What even happened?
How did you die?
Was it the meat guy?
I ate raw meat.
Oh!
You try now, Phoebe.
You eat the meat.
I try?
Okay.
Meat tag.
Oh.
Oh!
Oh, wait!
No, I tried to revive you, but I'm just pushing you.
Wait, what?
Wait.
Oh, wait.
Oh!
I'm dizzy.
Do not shake babies!
Wait, how do we wake you up, baby?
Wake up!
Why do I wake up?
Why won't I wake up?
I'm trying to revive you.
Wait, Vicky, can you revive her?
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
What happened?
Out of revives.
What do you mean out of revives,
huh?
Okay.
Can you guys hear me?
Can they hear me?
Yeah.
Yeah, we can hear you.
I have a nice relax.
Get this baby in the car.
Okay, baby.
Then you'll have a nice rest.
You'll be fine.
I'm gonna pick up all our stuff so that we aren't littering,
you know.
Oh, that's very responsible.
We got some scrap metal.
That's very responsible of you, you're right.
I got anything to help Phoebe be not dead in there.
Oh, did you feel that?
What happened?
I did.
I got smacked.
There's a repair hammer.
I'm okay.
I will.
I'm as okay as I can be, I guess.
Here, Phoebe, take a load off.
Take a load off.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I like how it's off.
on the grill.
Wait, wait, there's an EpiPen!
Wait, Phoebe, I can revive you!
Let me get in!
How did you get in?
Oh, thank you.
There you go.
Upies.
There you go!
One more out here.
There's one more out here.
Okay, let's take it with us.
We will take it with us.
Yeah, someone grab it.
This one, this one.
Oh, let's bring the ball to it.
I got it.
We definitely need to bring the bays.
Hello?
Over.
Relax and increase.
Hello?
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Yeah, I can hear you.
Talk with the, try the walkie-talkie.
Talk with this.
What is the walkie-talkie?
Right here, right there.
Talk with that.
With this.
Okay.
Hello.
Can you hear me?
Over.
Yeah.
It makes your voice sound funny.
Oh, wait!
Hello?
Over?
Wait, no.
I'm afraid of taking it under right.
Hello?
Over.
I'll put it under water.
I'm not a friend.
Hello?
Over?
Can you hear me?
How do I sound over?
Over?
Okay, I can hear you over.
I think I am electrocuted over.
You want to electrocute it?
Over?
No, I'm just kidding.
Oh, wait.
Phoebe, after your raw ham incident...
Have you got a broken bone?
I think my bones are broken.
Oh, me too, yeah.
Oh, nice.
Okay.
We have actually broken bones.
We have broken bones.
Wait, how did that break our bone?
Yeah, it was fine.
How do we do that?
Oh, there's a manual.
Wait, should we read this?
Sure.
Yeah, maybe.
Reading.
Oh.
What's it say?
Oh...
Oh, there's a lot that you have to do in this game.
Oh!
Oh...
Um, here you go.
Someone else can read it.
Be all prepared.
What's this saying?
Oh, I'll do it.
I don't know if you're busy throwing bears at me.
What does this say, Phoebe?
Okay.
So there's a winch on the front and on the back of the car.
A winch!
Oh, I found it!
I got it!
I got the winch!
Oh, winch.
The winch.
And then you can use it to put a stake in the ground and
stay there.
Aw, dang it.
You can repair things.
You have to repair things.
What did you just do?
Nothing?
How far can it go?
The wedge!
Yo!
Let's go!
Oh, I thought I could, like, spring myself off it.
That's a shame.
How do you get inside?
Am I just too short?
You jump, isn't it?
Oh, yeah.
I mean, you guys are kind of short.
Oh, I got in.
Let's go.
Oh, you did it!
Yay!
Um, let's see.
I guess I'm on a leash now.
That's our pet, Phoebe Chan Cheebe.
Yeah, little dog Phoebe.
If we start driving, we'll get dragged behind the car.
I wonder.
Let's try it out.
I was like, I don't know if I'm curious enough, but you know
what?
We can try it out.
Oh, there's a cool car.
Toggle park.
Oh, doggy, do you want some raw meat pie?
Oh, I'm in.
There you go.
Oh, yes, yes.
Take you to take you.
clutch what's happening oh wow it is manual oh i've been
lied to can you drive manual mental no i have attempted
gonna go wow so uh i'm going number one could try at some
point how do i you can do it i believe in you i'm packing
the car with coffee okay for if you get sleepy on the road
toggle engine go a kettle maybe the to-do list is oh oh oh
go home maybe you got you gonna come in oh well i'm still
wait i'm still attached let me hold on let's see well what
happens if we drive on while you're attached i'm kind of
intrigued i'm kind of curious too you want to try let's try
wait how do i hold on Oh, okay, this is reverse.
Vicky is from the UK.
You should have more of a chance to know how.
I don't know what manual means, chat.
Okay, I'll go to first position.
Here we go!
Phoebe, Jay!
Phoebe!
I'm coming.
I'm on my way.
She's still there.
Our dog's still there.
Do you see me through the... Do you see me through the
window?
Yeah, I see you through the window.
Yeah, I see me running from my...
running wait why are you running uh how do i park oh to keep
up okay actually what happens how do i get off out of here
oh exit vehicle okay will i get dragged okay
i think i want to go inside now i think doggy i need to go
to second gear to to up the hills someone else can drive i
think so what second okay i'll give it a go second game okay
what does that mean what are these buttons oh there's a oh
there's a controller wait febe where are you oh you've got
taken off there's a controller this whole time hey what for
what i guess for uh for here let's see let's see let's
attach it to you again oh okay yeah all right okay all right
run run far that way all
right wait uh what does this mean press clutch switch to
rear oh toggle paw oh uh toggle switch it to oh
Wow, wow, look at this!
Oh!
This is the...
Wait, Vicky's driving up!
Just go through!
Pass through!
I'm trying to clip through!
I'm trying!
What?
What's going on?
Alright, you really are stuck.
Oh my god, I'm stuck, stuck.
Here, you can go to the winch.
Okay, I'll go to the winch.
I'll reset the winch.
Okay, I'll reset.
Vicky?
Why is there meat patty on the ground?
I must reset Phoebe.
Oh, oh, oh, geez.
I'm all the boys.
Stuff is slow now.
Wait.
Our grill!
Pizza!
I did my best.
Oh my god.
What did you guys do?
You guys, I was not here for this.
Okay, yeah, you're right.
You were with me.
Vicky, what did you do?
I don't know.
Our grill.
Are the windows smashed?
No.
I've never seen the world so diagonally Oh, oopsie.
Okay, hold up.
We appear to have trees in the ceiling.
That's not going to cause it to set on fire, is it?
You know, let a load off.
There you go.
Have a beer.
That'll solve all the problems.
Okay, hold on.
Wait, can't we push it if we drink the beer?
That's what the manual said.
Oh, really?
Oh, yeah.
Wait, I'm pushing the car.
I'm pushing it.
I think I'm super human.
Let's go.
Have a beer.
This is denser to power.
How are you pushing it?
You just press F.
How do I pick up this beer?
Okay.
Pick up.
Chug, chug beer.
Chug beer.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Oh, oh, oh, here we go.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wait, how do you push?
F.
Oh, nice, nice.
A, A, A, A, ah!
Hey, hey, hey!
Should we decide what direction we want to push it in?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Are we all pushing it in different- Yeah, I think- This is
how we save Akiba with our superpowers.
Yeah.
We're gonna save Akiba.
I think the winch round may be like- Oh.
Maybe if you like attach it to something.
Hold on.
Yeah, maybe.
Yeah.
I'm gonna attach it to Phoebe.
Where should I attach it?
Okay, Phoebe, come here.
You're gonna pull it home.
I can't move.
Wait, reset winch.
Okay, hold on.
Where did I put it on?
Wait, does the beard in general make me stronger?
I don't know.
I might need another beard.
Wait, how do I get inside?
I reset the winch first.
Reset.
How do I reset it?
How do I get inside?
Hold on.
Let's put this.
yeah sorry guys where can we where can we attach oh there's
a front and back winch okay I'm like trying to figure out
where we can attach this to um probably that rock over there
um why do we even need the RV can we just run with our own
two feet yeah but yeah you can in it wait there's a ladder
to get inside yeah so i'm trying to get up
oh yeah oh oh oh it hatch as well be more efficient oh to
drive straight and then no no just kidding oh i think you're
right i thought i i thought you were just saying in general
it might be more straight.
It's okay, Vicky.
It was your first time driving manual.
I think I did pretty good for my first time driving.
Yeah.
I wasn't there to see how this happened, but I'm sure you
were just fine.
Wait.
This is not your fault at all.
There was a goblin on the road and you tried to avoid
hitting him.
Yeah, exactly.
Okay, hold on.
Wait.
Oh.
Yeah, look.
You can do it, Minto.
Okay.
Bring you up.
I'm good.
Wait!
Oh, okay.
We're fine.
Oh, you can get inside like here.
Okay.
Flipatronic 2000 pickup attached to shelf.
What is that?
Oh, will that let you flip the van?
Yeah, I'm gonna floor it.
Flip the van.
I'm gonna floor it.
You're gonna floor it?
Okay, floor it.
Yeah.
Okay, floor it, floor it.
I'm gonna switch to two because that's a higher number.
I couldn't work out how to switch.
Am I in park or no?
I don't know how do you how are you supposed to tell oh it
says it down there okay oh that's okay okay we're stuck all
right we're it's not it's not we are like stuck oh yeah oh
wait maybe one oh I drove somewhere in it am I yeah it moved
I did move it did Wait, get out and watch.
Wait, I'm gonna reverse.
Oh, wait, here.
You're reverse, reverse.
Nothing's happening.
I'm gonna also push it.
I'm gonna go to five.
I'm gonna try four.
I'm gonna try.
I'm gonna try three.
I'm gonna try one.
Chat says start in one and as you get faster shift to two,
apparently.
Whatever that means.
We're not even, we don't even have speed, dude.
This is zero miles per hour, my god.
I could try and like wait down the bottom of the truck with
my ass.
You know what?
Maybe if you keep pushing and I reverse at the same time.
Okay, let me get another beer.
Which way?
Out of the trees.
Yeah, okay.
Yeah, out the trees.
Okay.
Push and I reverse.
Okay, okay.
Well, real quick, can you throw me a beer?
Throw two beers, one for me, one for Vicky.
Yeah, throw two beers.
Okay.
It is now too tall for my little stubby legs.
Thank you.
Okay, this is...
Lovely.
Thanks very much, Lank.
Yep.
I'm driving, I'm driving.
There you go.
Release the beer.
I'm driving, you're driving.
I'm driving.
All right, Vicky.
I heard that.
That was...
All right.
That was crisp.
Oh, I heard that.
Satisfied.
Yeah.
There we go.
Alright, we are.
We have so much super strength.
So much.
Yeah.
Yeah, push it.
Push it.
Push it real good.
Go.
Oh my god, that was nearly it.
Oh!
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Oh!
Um...
You're doing it!
What should I do now?
Um...
Uh...
Just drive!
Go fast!
Yeah!
Oh.
Backwards!
Backwards.
Try backwards.
Okay.
Oh.
I like how I'm just lighting up and having a beer over here
just watching this watching this unfold what's the what's
that do the lighting up it might be time for more beer more
beer push push push oh I think our thing is about to break
more beer more beer wait do I have a windshield that's a
good question do we need one do we need one are we pushing
this way where phoebe is oh god are you going backwards i'm
going backwards yeah okay good good good nice whoa mango
incredible okay now we push the back now we push the back
awesome wait i'm going oh oh oh i just my bad uh okay wait
where am i i'm pushing the wheel okay hang on that's not
helpful where am i oh my god i'm all disoriented okay i'm
driving and we're going we're going into one baby Yeah!
Yeah!
Oh!
Okay.
Just stay like this.
I'm reversing.
You can straighten out again.
Vicky!
Ah!
Oh!
I
saw with Vicky get hit by the car and go flying and then the
game was over.
She was the vehicle this whole time.
You can die in this game!
Yeah, this is probably the better outcome that we're
starting again to be honest.
That's fine.
Here, here, we got, pick up all of our supplies and we'll
just make it back in again, baby.
Easy peasy.
Pick up these epi pens.
Pick it up, pick it up.
Yeah, pick up the motor oil.
Pick it up, throw it in.
walkie-talkies pick it up throw it in I know how to drive
manual now everybody suppose the grill absolutely can we
grab anything not raw patties okay yo oh yeah oh yeah oh we
got music okay to play the music
Oh, I don't know.
All right, I'm ready.
I know how to do this now.
Oh, this is a bomb.
Wait, how fast do I need to be going?
I got you.
I got you, Dora.
I picked up.
I picked up baby, don't worry.
Thank you.
Oh, that was so scary.
I was so scared.
Not close.
Okay, we go.
One.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, I'm on the road.
I'm in control.
I know how to drive.
manual oh watch out for falling rock don't worry about it
yes three three three three three number three where we
going I don't know off the road no one knows wait
what did i just do oh um park i was showing the toilet wow
how do i get up oh my god we're trapped in here did you
close the door where are you guys oh oh there's a wait
excuse me it's been a very long trip and i'm I need to loot.
I need to use the loo You did use the loo.
No problem, Minto.
Wait, you can actually do this right there You can do what
sit and like Observe yeah, take a look take a look take a
look at what I'm doing
Yeah, you're on the you're on the toilet Hang on Hello,
Minto.
Yeah, why?
Privacy, please!
Yeah, I know.
Oh, the grill is in one of the storage.
It's in here.
There.
Oh, lovely!
Lovely!
Dude to cave in, the road is closed.
Good old barbecue, that's what we need.
Get some burgers.
Do I have to go this way?
Oh.
We might have to.
I think so.
I think we have to make it so that the tires go on top of
the...
Oh.
No, no.
Maybe?
There are woodplants.
There are lots of woodplants.
Oh, are there?
Oh.
Oh, I think we have to go over the...
Oh, no.
The road's closed.
Wait, what was this one?
What does it say?
I thought there was another.
Due to cave in the road is closed.
Yeah.
What does that mean?
Surely there's always a cave in the...
What do you mean?
We could just...
Yeah, it's just a little dark, but we have lights.
Yeah, it's fine.
Oh, I think I just made that worse.
Oh, I find more.
I'm not really sure I'm helping.
Yeah, I think I'm better off looking for wood.
Where is there more?
Oh, this looks lovely.
good job guys good job yeah I think I think I made it worse
I'm sorry
no there's nothing everything you touch turns to gold oh
that's so sweet I can be supervisor yeah yeah there looks
good what's that mean oh supervisor I'm looking for wood I'm
in need of wood yeah Yep, looks good to me.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, more of that, baby.
Work harder.
Like that?
Okay.
More wood.
Okay, I'm...
Go get more.
Wait, how are you finding wood?
I know you work so, so, so hard for your six-figure salary.
Uh-huh.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I know I need to get on your level.
It's a skill issue.
I'm up on this hill, guys, and you will find the wood.
I think this is doable.
I think this is fine.
okay i think we could just drive like this yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay i'm gonna try it yeah fantastic job guys
well done all right let's go baby in we get all right buckle
up everybody it's about to get bumpy oh dear
I don't like the sound that loud.
There we go.
Don't worry about it.
Oh, it's probably, look at everything.
Oh!
Oh, it worked!
Oh, we're here!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, it actually worked!
No way!
Oh, my bad.
What the heck?
I
wanted a convertible I I just okay you guys I just upped our
vehicles value by like $200,000 okay like Yeah to be fair
probably true Yeah for stargazing and and smelling the fresh
air Yeah And it never rains in these parts so we don't even
have to worry about it Probably That's nice I'm excited to
stargaze with you guys It's a fantastic idea, Min.
I can see why you did it deliberately.
I, yes, yes.
I am a genius in the ways of...
Oh, okay.
Uh, where am I going?
Oh, Lordy.
Where am I?
Did you just say, oh, Lordy?
You guys, there's houses here.
We don't need to go anywhere.
Oh, uh...
Let's go burgle them.
What?
I mean...
Yeah, I'm stealing their scrap.
Whoa!
Ah!
Are you okay?
That's not a stick!
Ah!
Oh my god!
Wait, can we eat it?
Can we eat it?
No?
Oh, it's out!
What the hell?
Is she dead?
Oh, I got the antidote!
I got the antidote!
Oh, watch out.
Thanks, guys.
Wait, can you take...
Oh, I'm... I don't... Wait.
Let's see if there's a weapon around here, maybe.
I got some bear spray.
Maybe that'll work.
Oh, maybe.
Oh, my God.
There's snakes in the house everywhere.
I got some lotion.
Yeah, we need to be the snake eaters, guys.
Yeah.
That almost just gets snaked again.
The rain.
And someday we'll put snake on the grill.
Snakes on a plane.
I'm gonna eat a tree frog.
I'm sorry, I really like that line.
Guys, chainsaws!
Oh, no, it's scrap metal, never mind.
Oh, where?
Oh, dang, dang.
Round the back.
Why don't they move, though?
Like, once they...
Oh, they do kind of...
They switch a little bit.
No, they dance.
They booty dance.
So much good stuff in the house.
There's, like, beard.
We have nothing to scare them off with.
I'll get in there.
Can we just push him?
Right, I'm going to try and push one.
Okay, I'm inside.
There's nothing in here.
You're inside?
Yeah.
Oh, there's hats and stuff in here.
Wait, where's the beer?
You said there was beer in here.
I saw it in the other one.
What?
Oh, I put one inside of the RV.
Oh, okay.
Okay, nice.
We do.
Okay.
Wait, what's in here?
See if we can repair our roof.
No.
Why do you want to do that?
You know what?
Yeah, maybe it's fine.
It's fine with it.
Oh, you know what?
I think we need some burgers.
That's what I think we need.
Hey!
We got another grill.
I think that would heal my poison.
Yeah, how do I use it?
I think you just turn it on, no?
Closeable grill.
Oh, so you got that?
Wait, who's poison?
How do you use it?
Just turn it on, Vicky.
I am poisoned.
Oh, I took the antidote.
I'm fine.
Fire up.
Nice.
Ooh, fire up.
Hey, it's cooking.
Who wants the first meat patty?
I can deal with being 80% poison.
I think it's fine.
We should save the antidote.
Whoa, whoa, it just popped into a burger.
Whoa, it just became a burger.
Oh my God.
Wait, I want to see the burger.
Wait, Phoebe became a burger?
Yeah, yeah, just come here.
Yeah, you just, you just take one of the meat patties and
then you put it on the grill.
Yeah.
Put it on here.
Watch this.
It's magic.
It's like popcorn.
Oh, my love.
Oh,
yeah, yeah, let me see.
I can kick and ban you.
I'll just up the whole game.
Arigato.
Yeah.
Loss.
Buns and all.
This is awesome.
Mmm, an okay burger is the soft burger.
Oh, there's different burgers, guys.
Oh, there's different types.
Oh, wait, can I also become a burger?
What a flavor you like.
What a grill.
Here, hold on.
Try it.
All right.
Fry me up, baby.
Oh, man, she's hot.
She's hot.
It's like a hot stone sauna, but cheap version.
Yeah.
really safe i don't think anything's happening unfortunately
oh man oh well can we turn it off to save the grill for
later i don't think so oh so maybe we should keep making
load up burgers yeah make all the burgers burger up baby we
gotta go in the cabinet for later can't attach it you think
that's a thing like a fridge that's not a problem right what
what you just throw out very sauce there's also coffee here
if anybody wants a cold coffee a cold brew man cold coffee
no thank you I'm gonna put the burgers oh I'm gonna put them
oh I'm gonna put them oh I'm gonna we have no fridge guys
guys come out of the van you want to see where we're going
yeah you want to see where where we're headed to yeah my
butt valley my butt
my butt everyone in my butt's valley has a huge ass let's go
let's go i thought we were headed to twin peak man am i
still driving i mean anyone else want to give it a go i
would try yeah go ahead baby put it in one and then also two
and then three then you i've never been to four or five but
and then where are the oh i see i see oh oh i should sit
down huh um i feel like my big good there to be seated okay
surely nothing here we go what if i what okay what was the
was the was the was the is that how you drive is this oh yep
okay so then that should be that should be going forward
right okay otago park uh-huh trust you febe i trust you all
right we're going yeah It also goes to the left.
Yeah, we're going to go backwards.
Okay.
We're taking a quick driving break in seven minutes, by the
way.
We're having our little break, remember?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, in seven minutes already?
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
I wonder if there's a seat on the roof.
Watch something on our little mini-TV in the van, aren't we?
Oh, wait.
Oh, my God.
Does anyone have a link to it?
Choto, a minute.
I can organize that since I'm driving.
Choto, Choto, a minute.
Oh, I see.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so that's how you do it.
Oh, yeah!
Run into the sign.
Run into the...
Oh.
When I...
Oh, not bad.
When I did drive, I always needed to use a pillow to see
over the wheel.
And I feel like this that is the case here.
You're good.
Just go straight.
Go straight.
Oh, a little to the left.
Yeah, go straight.
You're good.
A little to the right.
Doing great.
Straight, straight.
You're good.
And then we can...
Oh.
I think you need to go to two.
I don't know.
It just started.
Howdy partner.
Oh, we weren't ready for three yet.
Nah, I think we're good in one.
Okay.
I'm in two.
Oh, there's a house!
Citizenship!
Oh, that's not a house.
Oh, it is a house.
Wait, what's that?
How do I get out of the driver's...
A rocket launcher!
Scrap metal.
A rocket launcher?
No, I was wrong, sorry.
Maybe you can use it on the snake.
We got some more beer.
Another EpiPen.
I feel like we...
Oh, antidote, sorry.
I feel like we definitely need that.
We definitely need that.
Anyone who's poisoned, use the antidote.
What is this?
motor oil.
Gregor doesn't seem to be here anymore.
Yeah, is there some kind of like underlying plot as to why
nobody's here?
The snakes.
A little jingle.
Oh yeah, what's happening?
Who's talking?
Is there, is there lore?
Away, away.
Away, away, away, away.
Oh, A wimboe.
A wimboe.
Where I teach you how to choose.
Absolute calm.
Now I know what you're thinking.
Austin.
What is this even coming from?
The radio, I think.
Maybe we stole someone, some guy's mixtape or something.
Maybe.
That sounds nice and all.
Well, it's not very good mixtape.
I don't have time for it.
Where's the mix?
Hey, girl.
I made your mixtape.
Whee.
Oh.
Are you also scouting where we're going?
Yeah.
I guess there's a road there.
Yeah, like kind of...
Oh, more scrap metal.
Oh, really?
Just kind of...
Oh, there's stuff in the trees.
I got burgers!
And bear spray.
Burgers!
Burgers in the trees?
I don't know if I trust that, Minto.
No, this is fine.
This is fine.
Are you sure?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is the good stuff.
This will make some fine grade...
probably been out for a few days but all right no no the
burgers where the bears put it just here just now the bears
we found some bear spray here let me shower you Phoebe oh I
just oh can I have some bear spray as well please oh I think
it was a one-time use cool okay so the bears come for me
then thank you guys are you okay did it work maybe the bear
makes the bears like you more.
I don't know.
It doesn't feel like...
Do I smell nice?
Do I...
Hmm.
Smells like beer and cigarettes.
Ooh.
It's working.
Wait, is...
I feel like a bear spray would be tangy like lime, no?
Can I give a little taste?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just a little bit.
No.
What?
Where are you going?
Well, it did say do not for consumption on the bottle.
It does probably say that.
Oh dear.
It's anti-bear spray.
Oh, here I was thinking it was gonna make bears be my
friend.
Wait, where'd you guys go?
Oh my god.
We'll pick you up.
I'll pick you up, I'll pick you up.
I'm getting lost.
Oh, I'm ready for you.
Vicky!
You snooze, you lose!
Thank you.
I think I'm...
Are you just holding me in the windscreen?
Yeah.
I'm not complaining.
You're so small!
One minute!
Maybe we should have our little, our little, you know, mini
TV in the RV break.
Yeah, okay.
Oh, you're right, you're right, you're right.
Although we might go off an edge.
Okay, no, no, no, good parking, good parking.
Okay, cool.
What's happening?
What?
Angle bear!
What's happening?
Oh, it's a bear!
The bear is here!
It's a bear!
We
need to repair the car while we were getting attacked.
Oh, but we reached a checkpoint.
It's fine.
That's why there was the bear spray.
Okay.
Well.
Talking of bears, you know what other creatures are scary
and might attack you?
Crocodiles!
Yes!
Yeah!
We're gonna watch a crocodile!
Wait, can I switch to Discord talk?
Because I won't be able to hear you guys after.
Yes.
Okay, unmute on Discord.
It's time.
Oh, wait.
Can you...
Wait.
Can you hear me?
Yes.
Okay.
Uh...
Oh.
Baby?
We're going to...
So for everybody confused...
Oh, we're doing that.
Okay.
Kairu Crocodile, the newest member of Beasties, is going to
be debuting.
And she has her debut animation.
And we're going to watch it.
Yeah!
Let me set it up real quick.
Sorry, sorry, sorry.
Woo-hoo.
Oh, no, no problem.
No problem.
I definitely should have done this before.
but that's okay no don't worry you still have you still have
a good like 40 30 seconds oh is it on the countdown oh it's
on the countdown okay we're good we're good okay all right
let me also let me just adjust it just don't worry too much
about sharing with us we can always watch it ourselves so
okay sorry i has it open in a tab all right i'm gonna turn
it on and hope that it's not super
That countdown is always so loud.
Oh my god, I just had to turn it down.
Jump scare.
Sorry, guys.
Oh, oh, oh, okay, here we go.
Oh, three, two, one.
I'm a little behind you, but that's okay.
Woo!
Oh, it's pretty.
It's so cute.
It's pretty.
Oh, it's pretty.
I love his style.
Yeah, I like the style.
I like how it's like very like watercolor-y kind of.
It's really nice.
This guy is...
His hat, he needs it.
He needs it.
It's necessary.
It's a pretty good hat, to be fair.
He is.
He won't be Monkey D.
Luffy without it.
King of the Pirates.
This is like the worst idea ever.
This is...
Why do I feel like we'll be doing this in the game?
Oh?
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
I want that to happen to me.
Get jaws.
Wait, I'm turning off the subtitles.
Oh, he's getting burgled.
No!
Oh no, he had a rifle.
back at home.
The animation is so good.
Wow!
It is so good.
Oh, he's freaking dead!
Cute!
Oh!
Boy, you never seen a worm with a cigarette dance to Jingle
Bell Rock?
Now this is a GUI stream, yes!
What?
Oh, we just see him!
Oh!
See you, see you!
Here's what I say to them.
Tier 3 Discord?
This is such a cute way.
Cut your girlfriend too.
Listen, I'm a milky girl.
Yeah.
This is so cute.
Wow.
Computer barn.
Nice.
That's where I get all my stuff to.
Where will she plug it in?
At a computer barn.
Burgle the barn.
The animal control!
The animation is so good!
So nice.
I hope she got her RAM before it became expensive.
The gamer keyboard.
The RGBs.
Wow.
Oh, that was so good.
That was so good.
That was so cute.
So wow.
Oh my gosh, I am so, so excited to see what kinds of content
Kairou makes.
Beasties, Beasties, Beasties, Beasties love.
Beasties, love.
I'm going to show you guys.
I know you're okay.
I don't, I watched this.
Oh, this is, I'm on the Densetsu account.
These are, these are the, I was like, what is happening?
to the recommendations.
I want to see the recommends.
Wait, what does it look like?
It's like this musical, an anime musical, and then an old
man's advice.
I was like, oh, I wonder what a little show for my
recommended, but then, and like, it's just old man.
Steiner?
What is he watching?
Anyway!
Yay!
Sorry.
But that was a good little intermission, everybody.
It was.
She has a...
She has a... What's it called now, though?
A waiting room up.
Oh, did you guys already mute?
Okay.
Oh, what is...
When is the waiting room for?
Like, when is it for?
I don't know.
I didn't check.
Wait, hold on, I'm going to look.
Kairu Krakato.
Oh, there.
Oh, it's for...
Oh, two days!
Sorry, sorry, not muted yet, so...
Sorry.
In two days!
Friday!
Yay!
Exciting!
Cool.
Oh, sorry, I forgot to mute on Discord.
What?
Okay, I'm muting on Discord now.
go back into the game this is the game right okay yay make
sure that you're there guys at 13th december 9 a.m jst
whatever your time zone is woohoo yummy i think that's 5 p.m
pacific i think i think 4 p.m be there 4 4 p.m pacific 7 p.m
eastern be there yeah
Wait, guys, there's emotes!
Oh, guys, we can't stay on Discord because we...
We even played Rock, Paper, Scissors!
The game was not letting us turn off the in-game audio.
So that's why we stick to the in-game audio.
And then you can play...
Rock, Paper, Scissors.
Okay.
Are you ready?
Wait, what is happening?
You got your choice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
What's happening?
Hello?
Okay.
Well, there's a...
There's a...
Oh, yeah, wait.
Minto, I can't hear you.
Can you unmute?
Oh, oh, let me unmute.
Yeah, for go on.
Yeah, sorry.
So game was beat.
Uh, there we go.
They're just me in game, but not Mint.
So Mint has to be on Discord.
Yeah.
But then I have to turn Mint's Discord volume down for
myself.
But then she has to be unmuted for Vicky.
It's very cool.
Yeah, we were struggling with the audio.
We were trying to get it to turn off in game, but it
wouldn't.
So then if we had it in Discord, it was going to be doubled.
we were talking in discord and then we could only hear two
people at a time it was very scuffed so we were trying to
figure it out beforehand yeah it's all good now though all
right how about whoever loses rock paper scissors has to try
okay wait how do you do it was oh there it is okay i got it
press eggs and then you choose okay three two one press
paper oh we all did different things what does that mean
wait whoa whoa if those that's like our personalities i'm
the i'm the paper wait what's that mean wait we all did it's
a different choice it's a three way yeah i get scissors well
i don't know what that means guys so um wait we gotta get
the bear we gotta get the bear spray it's over here yeah
where'd the bear go where'd the bear go oh no i'm ready wait
there's no bear spray Wait, it's RNG.
Wait, oh no.
It's RNG.
What items do you get?
No!
That just means...
Really?
We have to just drive fast enough for the bear to not get
us, I guess.
I think so.
Okay.
Wait, really?
Wait, there's more stuff in here, too.
We got to get all this stuff again from the house.
Yeah.
Oh, that's the absolute...
The house.
Where am I going?
Oh, no, this way, Phoebe.
Oh, oh.
the beer follow me i don't know where i'm going okay um get
the beer okay cassette oh it's that weird thing yeah it's
that weird one again yeah i don't need that yeah i think
we're good oh no we have no bear spray okay wait all of our
burgers and stuff are going too oh what did the bear take
all of it oops It's okay, I've had the coffee too.
Are you serious?
I'm so... I'm so...
I'm so buzzy right now.
Do you have too much?
We could all...
I don't drink caffeine.
Don't have to ask me twice.
We can push the bear.
Maybe wait till we get near the bear.
Have your beer in your hand and then we can push the bear
away.
I'll have one in my hand.
Oh, okay, got it.
Okay, let's go.
Ready to push that bear.
Push that bear!
Oh, I have to start the car.
My bad.
Push that bear!
Wait, uh, I'm okay.
I'm not drunk.
Push that bear!
We're going?
It's just like a roller coaster.
Yeah!
Okay.
Don't worry about it.
Look out for bear.
We have one of those little scented things in the car too.
Makes it smell nice.
Which makes it scent is, guys.
It's a Christmas tree.
It's probably Christmas flavor.
Green flavor?
Scented.
Flavor.
You can taste it.
Christmas flavor.
Yeah.
I'm going to lick it.
Wrong.
Tight turn, everybody!
Oh.
Don't worry about it.
I got this.
You got this.
I.
I got this Nice I mean, you're so good at driving I know,
actually Actually, actually, yeah How are you getting out of
these situations?
Uh oh, there's a bear coming There is I heard him I'm ready
for him Oh, do I need to be in two?
No Go Wait, am I stuck?
I'll be on bear lookout Why am I stuck?
Why am I stuck?
There's like There's like like a ditch at the upper end of
the van, but I feel like if we push it, it might be alright.
Push, push, push!
Yeah, drink your beer and push!
Oh, nice!
We're good.
Oh, okay.
I drank my beer anyway.
Oh, let's go.
Vibin.
It's okay.
We're good.
I might have left my beer can on the floor, so hopefully no
one will notice.
No one will notice.
Hopefully the bear?
Oh my gosh, what if it's the bear of litter?
And so he hates anyone who litters.
Yeah!
Oh!
Oh my gosh, it could be that.
Okay, that is a bit scary.
Yeah, I'm gonna floor it.
I'm gonna floor it.
Oh, Minto, we trust.
We trust.
In Minto, we trust.
Yes, Minto, yes.
Yeah.
Yes, Minto, we trust.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Did you guys put on your seat belts or what?
I mean, I was on the windshield, so no.
Are we okay?
Yeah, I don't know how.
I can't move, but other than that, yeah, sure.
I am feeling grand.
I'm feeling good, baby.
Wait, where's...
Oh, there you are.
Guys, I'm dead behind a tree.
Oh, thank you.
I got you.
Thanks, thanks.
Oh, I can revive both of you.
Yay!
Arigato!
Yeah!
Nice.
Wait, where are we?
Well, on the positive side, we discovered a new area.
Yeah?
This could be the hit new spot to drink beer.
And our place are...
I'm gonna repair the car.
Our car is totally fine.
Like, we are killing it.
Oh, get in the van.
You just gotta run.
You got this?
I wonder if there's anything up here.
Show me how it's done, Minto.
Okay, I got you.
I'm gonna get a running start.
That is a big run.
a little bit anticlimactic okay let me yeah i don't think we
can get in how did phoebe get in yeah how did you get in
phoebe oh sorry i went like from here oh oh the door oh
phoebe's turning his vote phoebe.exe oh did i turn to a
robot yeah just a little bit again oh i'm just phoebe.exe
right now do you need more scrap i got scrap oh you do Yeah,
I think it's a collective scrap, right?
Is it?
How many epi pens do you guys have?
I've got loads of scrap.
How do you see your inventory?
Oh, I think, okay, I guess it is shared then, because mine
says six.
Mine says six as well.
Oh, okay, okay.
Where do you see that?
Oh, six.
Okay, it is shared.
Yeah, yeah, it's at the top.
Am I still robot?
Nope, you're good.
Oh, wow.
Thanks.
Do I want to get in the van, though.
Oh, we could go in through the top.
Yeah, going in through the ladder.
What's the power hole?
What's that?
Where's the ladder?
Going in.
Where is the ladder?
Yeah.
Maybe, um...
Did we lose it?
We might have.
How have all of...
How have we been sleeping?
Oh, you can go in via the tree.
I can pick up anybody that would like to come in.
in oh we also in in the van oh oh you're behind me thank you
girl they're right behind me aren't they i guess i also
could have driven us a
we're fine everything's good oh yeah we're good oh yeah we
are now where are we i think the thing on the top is to flip
the rv if it flips over
Wait, where are we?
Are we good?
Um, I don't see a path.
I think we might get out in one.
Yeah, I'm gonna park here.
It's a little precarious, but don't worry about it.
Um, oh, that is a cliff we are about to drive onto.
Oh!
So...
It is...
Vicky, Vicky, Vicky, grab my head!
Wait, Vicky!
Vicky, grab my hand!
Vicky, throw your head!
Throw your head!
Vicky!
Oh, Vicky!
Whoa!
No!
Yes!
Dog live the king!
No!
Here, I'll come get you guys.
I'll come get you guys.
Okay, I'll stay here.
Yeah, yeah, just stay there.
There's gotta be a way to get down here.
Yeah, there is, there is, there is.
Potentially, like, it's steep, but, uh...
There ain't no mountain I can't climb.
If it goes up, it must come down.
Kills baby's there.
I need no...
Sorry, Phoebe, I know you just repaired everything, but,
uh...
Alright, hop on in, everybody.
Oh, thanks, Rizzo.
Oh, don't leave the beers.
We dropped some beers.
No!
We have enough.
Oh, yeah.
Must have dropped a beer.
Throw that.
How can I never get in?
There we go.
Is it getting darker or is it just me?
Alright, there's one other cliff we gotta go down.
Okay.
I'm just gonna back right into it.
Should we be...
Okay, should I close the door and be seated?
Oh, we don't...
Sorry, we don't have...
door oh we don't have a door wait hold on hold on we should
at least repair the door that's important okay okay that's
important all right hurry up how are we gonna go okay oh oh
oh my god oh ow
easy easy i was just about to be here sit back down i told
you bb you still as you lose That was so funny.
I was like sitting in my seat and Phoebe was repairing the
door.
Oh, we have a door.
We have a door again.
Oh, thank god at least the door survived.
Wait, I think there's a the thing here though, right?
I saw the the hammer The oh, where did the hammer go?
I saw it fly out.
I don't know where it went.
It flew out Oh Oh, I see you see you I found it.
Oh, you found it again.
Oh, thank god We must shouldn't, we need to get in here as
well.
I'm in the car, in the cabinet.
Wait, what?
My, I became a bag of bones.
You're in the- Yeah, Phoebe's dead in the back.
Sorry, I didn't see you there.
But your name's all the way up there.
Oh, is it?
Oh.
There you go.
Thank you.
Oh, why am I infinitely repaired?
Oh my god.
Do you guys see this?
I'm gonna...
We broke the game!
I died doing what I loved.
Oh my god.
I am infinitely repaired.
It's my trauma!
I can't stop jerk.
She's jorking him.
She can't stop.
It's the only thing that can make me feel something.
It's the only way I can feel anything.
Just lay down in the bed to get some nice rest.
Oh.
Val's still being jorked in the back.
Wait, wait, I know.
Wait, how we can do this.
Yeah.
Um, paper beats rock.
Oh, you're right, hold on.
Hold on, hold on.
Maybe if I rock paper scissors, it.
Oh, oh, it actually fix you.
It fixed you.
Oh my gosh.
I thought I would be a chronic jorker forever, but I will
not It's an addiction and it's very serious It's very
serious I didn't even have to go to rehab Guys, I don't
think I should drive anymore So glad you're feeling better,
Phoebe Thank you Phoebe, you drive, how about you drive
because you know You've been kind of getting beat up a
little bit You guys want me to drive again?
Anyone want to suggest me drive?
Let me look at where we're supposed to go I mean, whatever
makes you happy, but I will do my best.
I think you should just keep sipping that beer yours, Miss
Headless Hime.
Yeah, I think that's probably best.
Eternal Passenger Princess.
Probably good.
Yeah.
I'm just gonna have a beer, light one up.
Yeah, you need to go backwards.
There's, like, the cliff behind us.
Yeah, we gotta go up there.
Okay.
Let me see if I can...
can actually like turn nice nice nice nice nice nice nice
three point turn nice very nice yeah nice incredible look
your smoke is getting in my face wow all right yep keep
going you're doing great you're doing great oh now what okay
oh um i'm gonna see where we are oh a wall oh nice uh okay
uh i'm getting out oh don't run me over wait wait wait wait
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah be safe be safe be safe do we go
through there is that like where you are right now should
would you recommend that um do we have a wheel drive uh i
don't think going this way uh how are we gonna get through
here hmm oh do not get run over do not get run over oh
you're doing great you're doing great i say we just go with
our legs no that on foot might be the way uh oh you can
restart from a checkpoint so yeah we could like run
somewhere and then get the van oh hi minto hi Watch this.
Oh, so close.
It was so close.
We're gonna have to winch it.
Oh, we have to winch it.
How about I try and jump in there?
Do you think that'll work?
Okay, go, go, go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was sick!
Oh my god!
Let's go.
Let's see.
Um, what should we winch to where?
Yeah, to where?
Whom?
What?
Okay.
I winched!
Okay, you winched.
Okay.
Should I drive?
Yeah, use the controller to pull.
Controller.
Okay.
Ah, I'm gonna close the door.
There you go.
Um, Vicky, could you turn to the left as I do this?
Thank you.
Just turn the wheel to the left as we do this.
Turn the wheel.
Oh, turn the wheel.
Yeah.
Yeah, good job.
That is left, right.
Okay, that's left.
That's coming for me.
Nice.
You can do it, Vicky.
Okay, you don't have to turn anymore.
We're good.
Uh, cool.
I can make it.
I'm a stinking goat.
What am I?
Yeah.
I can run up walls.
It's pretty good.
Whoa.
Must have fives of steel run up that steep.
Yeah.
Okay, now I'm going to attach it to a tree up.
It's up there.
Okay.
Wait.
Do I need to do...
Tell me if I need to do it.
Should I turn right?
Wait.
I can't move.
Why could I move before and now I cannot move?
Wait, can you turn it off?
Actually, can you turn off the winch?
Oh, Terry reset the winch?
Don't...
I don't think you need to reset it.
I think you just need to turn it off.
Turn it off.
Oh.
How we do that?
Maybe you do need to reset.
I don't know.
I'm just gonna reset it.
Yeah, reset it.
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
I'm attaching to a tree.
You can do it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Up here.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Winch it.
Let's go.
And floor it.
Vicky, floor it.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
come here um dead what what's dead what's dead i mean i'm
dead in a bush wait what happened to you how did this happen
where are you where are you i'm in a bush behind the back
i found her she's here just get her in the car i wanted to
see how how high i could go not that high apparently
more facts thank you thank you very much okay now we will we
will winch winch winch winch winch winch winch winch oh
winch winch uh avoid the tree
good job good job looking really good guys well done all
right all right all right all right there There might be a
tree in the van, but that's fine.
Oh, don't worry about it.
Ta-da.
Oh, I wasn't even in gear.
That's why we're going too slow.
Guys, you're doing so well.
Hey, I'm gonna...
Would you like me to undo the winch?
Yeah, undo the winch.
Okay.
Reset winch!
Have I seen to have fallen off the bed?
Hopefully I'll be fine.
Where are you?
I think I'm running into a tree.
I got you.
Oh, thanks, Phoebe.
Uh, yeah, I'll get you.
I'll get you.
You are, in fact, running into a tree.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just turn to the right.
Yeah, you're good.
Oh, what?
Uh.
Maybe back up a little bit first.
Yeah.
Back up a little.
Oh, what?
What if I go this way?
Yeah, like that.
That should be good.
Okay.
You can go straight here.
Straight?
Oh, um, no.
Yeah, you're like out of the way of the trees now.
Here, let me try.
Let me try push.
Push me!
Oh, wait.
Go on, baby!
Come on!
Push!
Oh, that's a ledge.
That's a ledge.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
You know what?
I think it's time to winch it.
Oh.
Oh, oh, I went back into the tree.
I'm back into the tree.
Don't die.
Okay, we can try winch again.
dead yeah i'm gonna try wishing to another trees to move out
the way yeah oh good job we will have to turn to the right a
little bit okay look at oh my gosh our van is so like oh are
you okay are you okay over here how am i still smoking what
i'm saying because it's a tough habit to kick you know Yeah,
I guess so.
All right, I'm turning to the right.
Oh, my God.
What was that?
That was the whole side of the car.
What?
You know, this is how they design like really nice
apartments these days, right?
Like leaves everywhere.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's a very all-natural.
Yeah.
Very more each other.
Oh, gosh, we can only tangle a little bit more, guys.
Okay, hold on.
Let me, I'm gonna un-winch it.
Okay.
We are, like, there's a tree right.
We are, like, right going into a tree right now.
So we back up.
You got this?
Back up?
Oh.
This freaking tree.
Yeah, just a little bit.
Because we're on the, we are very close to the edge.
Oh!
You know, if we, if you can turn, like, if we can turn it
this way somehow.
Like that way?
Yeah, that's what I was trying, but it wouldn't budge at
all.
Hmm
Oh, that's why I'm not backing up.
Okay.
Hmm.
Yeah, guys, um We might have to reach the hot.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, oh my god, we're fine.
Oh, oh, oh.
I'm driving to the right.
but it keeps pushing me over here.
It keeps pushing you there.
Yeah, for some reason.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, okay, good.
And then, yeah, I guess keep going to the right a little
bit.
Maybe that's counteract it trying to make you go to the
left.
No, it's still making me.
Let me drink a beer.
I'm going to drink a beer.
Push me!
Where are beers?
Do we have any more beers?
Yeah, go, baby, go.
Where are the beer?
Oh, there.
Underneath the table.
Okay.
I'm taking the six pack.
Sorry!
Sorry, so sorry.
Wait, but doesn't this put us back at the bridge?
That's where we died the first time.
Yay!
Oh, that was good!
That would save us so much time!
You know?
Maybe we won't fall off the bridge this time.
I think somebody else should drive over the bridge.
There's a bear spray, guys!
There is?
Oh, nice, nice!
Yeah!
Oh, thank God.
Oh, nice.
Okay, maybe the bear will come this time.
Oh, and burgers!
Yeah!
Oh, my gosh, we should have done this ages ago.
All right.
Nice.
I'm ready with the bear spray.
I'm ready to spray, guys.
All right.
Who's driving?
I mean...
You can.
I can.
Yeah, you can do this.
Would you like to?
You want to try?
You should try.
I think you should try.
Yeah.
Okay.
who's who's having the best right here believe in you okay i
didn't understand how you switch gears or anything it's q
you hold it and then you go to number one i saw you go to
number one right am i sitting i should be sitting the car is
straining to keep up the speed then you can go to
for a bus okay
all for a bus yep yes and then oh no no in the queue you
press q and then you do the q and then you go to r okay and
but you still would go forward you still you still use a w
on there i'll go push you Oh Let's make you drive Oh Oh
Seems to be alright Maybe?
Oh When is it?
It died over What happened?
Phoebe,
do you want to come see the problem?
So see, Shree here?
yes and sea tree here how did you do it guys i told you i
shouldn't have been driving hold on hold on vicky it's okay
um i'll take over for you we're gonna try something i think
i think that's for the best i i think that should have
probably been the case from the beginning i'm just gonna
have a beer and sit down i'm gonna watch it happen that's
okay here um i'm not sure that sure this will help actually
i really don't think this is gonna yeah yeah um so so the
fact of the you know what we're gonna do we're gonna have
hey we're gonna we're gonna do something we're gonna do
something we're gonna use the winch it's gonna be okay
cheeky little side winch cheeky little side winch cheeky
little side winch she's my side winch she's my side My wench
on the side.
Your side, the wench.
It's not a very nice thing to say about me.
Oh, that's coming at me.
There, we're good.
Oh, wait, oh, shoot.
Is that what I am to you guys?
Just the wench on the side.
But the tires, they call to me.
Okay, can someone reset to the wench?
The wench.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, park, park, park there.
Do it.
Do it, Phoebe.
Go on, Phoebe.
Is it?
Okay.
All right.
I'm in.
Oh, was that a bear?
Oh, the bear!
Who has the bear spray?
Where's the bear?
He's behind here.
He's at the...
Where?
The bear is at our rear.
Oh, my God.
Someone repair the...
Repair while we drive.
Okay, I'm going to jump off the thing and go get him.
Get
him!
You sprayed him?
Come here.
Come back.
Come back, come back.
Come back in.
I'm coming.
Okay.
Are you here?
No.
Wait for me!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here.
Okay, oops, oops, oops, oops, oops.
Okay, there.
Woohoo!
Oh yeah, I do that too.
Wait, who am I hitting?
What the?
You're still alive, aren't you?
Isn't right?
Is it right?
We're fine, everything's good!
I want it to be bonked by...
Bonked with the minto hammer.
Everything's good!
Alright!
You can make it, Phoebe!
You can go over the bridge!
Oh, Phoebe!
Okay, you can make it.
I'm gonna prepare first.
Just line it up, line it... Here, I'll help you.
Take your time.
Ah!
Oh, God!
We got this!
Keep going.
Oh my god.
The winch.
Oh god.
Okay.
Okay, you can do...
Vicky, you have the controller.
You have the controller.
Guys.
Yeah.
I can get in.
Look out of the bad.
and then down and that's all there.
We're fine.
Oh, I'll leave you down there.
Shoot.
Phoebe's head is blocking it on the screen.
I exited out of the door straight off the bridge.
It's okay.
I'm inside.
Oh, you are too.
You're inside?
Yeah, I'm inside.
Go, guys.
Go.
Get to a checkpoint.
Bring me back.
Don't worry about me.
Hold on.
We will get you.
where are you what's going on with the car why are we tilted
like this oh because we're not good i wouldn't come down
here because you will also die can you just respawn me at
the checkpoint i guess we'll have to try don't touch this
prickles okay okay oh okay you okay yeah i'm good park here
yeah park here yeah park you i'm gonna see i'm gonna check
out where we're big yeah me too i'm that's what i'm trying
to do wait i think i
Don't go down the sheer drop.
That is the advice I will give you.
Oh, that's where you are.
Oh.
I have to winch to mint and drop down there.
Oh, yeah, you were so right.
Hold on.
Wait, you can do that.
Okay, drop, drop me.
Drop me.
In my defense, there's burgers down here, so you'll get some
burgers as well.
Oh, there's like a little prickle behind you.
Oh, oh, I see.
All right, I'm going down.
There's burgers down there?
There's burgers down here Wow, I can only pick up one thing
Vicky.
I don't know.
You shouldn't have told me that
Can you drop me right in front of me?
I can see them Oh, no, I can see someone.
It's me.
Thank you for coming to save me Drop I can't go down
anymore.
I can't go down anymore.
Oh, shoot Okay, I'm gonna try backing up the car a little
bit.
Okay.
Okay, I'll try backing up the car Wait, I don't know about
that.
I don't know about that I'll try to be careful.
I'll try to be careful.
Can you see me?
Oh, my Lord.
You look majestic.
You look like a beautiful bird flying on the wind.
She was a fairy.
A fairy.
Did it help at all?
Did it back you up a little bit?
No, but I might be able to...
I might be able to let go and then climb up.
I'm gonna try that.
And then you...
So just leave the winch here, okay?
Oh, God.
Okay.
Okay, here I go.
And don't be careful.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Oh?
Where am I going?
Wait, oh, I have to drop it.
Oh.
Wait, if I drop it, does it retract?
Drop the base.
Okay, it stays.
It stays.
Don't reset the winch.
Don't re- Oh, nice.
Okay.
There's some buggies over there too if you want them.
Wait, wait!
Me!
What is happening?
Uh, well, bad news is karma might have just karma.
I cannot see, I cannot see over the cliff.
What is, what is going on down there?
Chat, you're gonna have to describe it to me.
Oh, I could have just...
Hi, baby.
Call yourself Burgers.exe.
Oh, hi, you guys.
Whoops.
Well, welcome back.
Do the- What?
Just drop the burgers again.
Karma is a sweet thing, don't you think, everyone?
What?
You know what?
I just realized.
I could have just...
I could have just revived you.
I could have just revived.
Yeah!
Exactly!
Come on, Minto.
Yeah, make the right choice.
Oh, there's lotion down here too.
I suppose I'll forgive you.
Wait, there's more burgers.
What's over here?
No, you dropped the burgers.
I saw them drop from above, Minto.
It's the same burgers.
It's the karma.
Okay, come this way.
Come this way.
Okay.
Me?
No, no, no.
I'm talking to...
Yeah, Vicky, Vicky.
Okay.
I'm still just going to wait for you guys.
I was going to come back for you.
Yeah, sure you were, sure you were.
Oh, we're close to the ocean.
Beware the spikies.
Spikies?
Yeah, these.
These bad boys.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, okay.
It was pretty hilarious when I saw the burgers drop down.
Oh, welcome back.
Oh, thanks, Vee-Vee!
Yay, welcome back, Vicky!
We're back!
And we have burgers, so it was all worth it in the end,
wasn't it, guys?
Oh, we need to repair it real bad, don't we?
How can I not get up?
Okay.
I'm going to repair.
Why can't I repair?
There's the bear still just on the bridge.
I doubt it, right?
I think we knocked the bear off.
He ran away.
I think Phoebe drove over him.
No, I think Phoebe drove over him.
No, I definitely saw him run away.
Oh, okay.
I'm going to get ahead a little bit.
I think I was hitting someone.
Like, could you sit and so proper?
Aw, straight and so proper.
What happened?
What the heck?
Let's see, I'm an eye and I'm sideways.
You good, Phoebe?
For some reason, I went fully to the left when I tried to go
straight.
Oh, no.
Oh, Phoebe.
What happened?
Oh, I'm winging it.
I'm winging it.
Oh.
Oh, Phoebe.
Oh, oh, I see.
Oh, I see.
Oh, that is a rock.
That is a massive...
Yeah, that's a rock.
That's a rock.
Oh, wait, hold on.
How do I do this?
Oh, wait, we can reset it, right?
Okay, there we go.
Okay, we use the back winch.
That's what I'm doing.
Can we just pull backwards?
Okay.
Then I'll get rid of the front winch.
I'm on it.
Which one is it?
Can I do anything?
You're so short.
You are helping.
I will be motivation.
Yeah, get it.
Yes, get it, girls.
Yes.
Work it.
Get that wench.
Yeah.
You can do it.
Is there any way you could push?
Me.
Push which way?
From the front?
Yeah.
Yeah, let me get some beer.
Can you chop me a beer, Phoebe?
Yeah.
Is it out or in?
Which one is it?
Thank you.
Yes.
Right.
Push from this side, right?
Yeah, right.
I'm gonna trug and push.
Or wait, maybe we go forward instead because the rock is too
big.
Yeah.
Perhaps.
Maybe.
Hold on, I'll reset this.
I think it seems to be doing something.
Is that helping?
We are going backward.
Oh, you are.
Wait, you are.
Wait, let me do it again then.
Oh, wow.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to keep going reverse then.
Oh, I don't think the reverse will do anything.
Where did I put the remote?
Oh, there.
Oh, wait.
Is it working?
Kind of, yeah.
You did!
Woo-hoo!
Do you need me to drive backwards or forwards or anything?
Well, we gotta keep going this way, so I don't know how you
want to...
keep winching it for now okay okay are we are we off the
rock yeah we're way off the rock okay oh you might want to
hurry oh nice oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait the winch the winch release yeah it needs to be
released okay you're good you're good okay uh maybe move a
little bit because i don't want to run you over like re's
position if you can okay oh what happened oh oh oh this is
just naturally oh i think you can reverse though you can
reverse though i can reverse now yeah yeah yeah if you're
like reverse up the path something yeah yeah just keep going
keep going here but i'm trying to figure out which which
which way to reverse in general okay okay nice uh-huh okay
then crank it
yeah nice nice okay we're back in business baby okay back in
the van everybody yeah we have a door yeah we have a door we
have burgers we have everything we need our car yeah we're
totally fine everything's good life is we got beers yeah let
me just see where we're supposed You gotta go to the left.
To the left.
Oh, I thought we had a windshield.
I thought so as well, but...
Apparently it's not.
Alright, you got this?
You got this?
You got it.
Floor it.
I'm so scared.
Okay.
There's a little... There's a cut...
Shortcut if you want to go to...
Yeah, to the right.
Okay, to the right.
Keep going to the...
I was just doing a bit of casual modding.
Keep going to the right!
Are we backwards now?
Yeah, we are.
Okay, so I'll just reverse it.
It's okay, we can drive this whole way backwards.
True, true, true.
Here, I'll help you out.
Okay, so what's going on here?
You gotta go forward and you gotta like kind of reposition a
little bit.
Okay.
Go forward and go to your left.
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
Okay, now you can- Oh, that was beautiful.
You kinda went a little crazy.
Oh, you're gonna reverse off the cliff.
You're gonna reverse off the cliff?
You're gonna- I think you're gonna go off the cliff.
Yeah, there's a big cliff there.
Oh, there's burgers down here.
More!
Wait, is that actually?
Wait, where?
I got him right now.
Oh, my hands.
Ay.
Let's go.
Ay, ay, ay.
So, okay, so this is the way we're supposed to go up here,
right?
Which way?
Up.
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Where did we come from?
Yeah, you're supposed to go that way.
Yep.
Okay.
Okay, what kind of what kind of what kind of?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Nice.
Good job, everybody.
Good job, Phoebe.
You got this?
Woo-hoo!
Thank you.
I'll try.
You could go in the circle again.
You could just go back down where you...
I could go in the circle again?
Yeah, if you drive up.
And you could just go to the left.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Yeah, circle around.
Can you go to the left?
Go to the left?
Yeah, yeah.
And then...
And then to the...
and then to the right.
Yeah.
Okay, we got some burgers in the meantime.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Come here.
Okay, don't roll me over.
Alright, we're back in business, baby.
Okay, nice.
We're back in business, baby.
I'm one.
Okay, there's another bridge.
Oh, short people problems.
Oh, disgusting.
Oh, no.
The burger's just...
Fell out the van, I think.
Oh, no, don't worry.
They're here.
You park.
With the thing going for me.
And then reverse.
You want me to line you up?
Yeah.
All right.
I'm going to line you up.
Why am I so small?
Huh.
Get some snacks on for you guys, for all your hard work.
Okay, here you go.
Okay.
All right.
Pull forward.
Should I just pull forward?
Yeah.
Okay.
be the driver.
Here you go.
Okay.
You're, uh, you can keep going.
Yeah, you're good here.
You're good.
Okay.
Good.
Yeah, you're good.
You're good.
Oh, wow.
You're a little, a little to your, uh, you're good.
Okay.
You're good.
Wow.
Oh, wow.
Oh, man.
Get back up there.
Keep going?
That was terrifying.
That was so terrifying.
Yeah, baby!
Woohoo!
Keep going straight.
Okay.
All right.
You guys think we're going the right way?
Sure.
I remember seeing that book.
Hang on, let me have a look.
Wait, what's that over there?
Is there construction going on around here?
This looks right, like down this way, right?
I don't think we've been here before.
Down this part that makes...
Oh, hang on, different part.
Oh, is there a path there, too?
Not down here?
Where?
Oh!
Is it parked down that way as well?
No, I don't think we've been down there yet.
Yeah, I don't think so.
This way, right?
of the there's a map there's a map oh there's been a map
this whole time by the way guys i've fired you up some
burgers for your hard work they're on the floor oh thank you
where are we guys wow look how much we've done wow wait
where's the exit this place is my butt my god this place is
the pit my butt i seem to fall on my butt a lot so yeah i'm
gonna have a burger actually i'm so hungry go for it i made
them for you guys oh sorry if i'm not driving or helping
it's the least i can do um excuse me sorry i'm not a burger
what what what wait i can't get the burger it's under the
table i'm trying oh no oh this one's absolute taste green
burger yeah absolute taste you made the best for you guys oh
it helped my health for real wow oh my gosh let's go let's
go i'm feeling burger duty helping you guys out yeah all
right you are helping us out all right we gotta go to the
Alright, okay.
I'm going to fire one up.
Have a little look at the surroundings.
Alright.
Chancheby, on the job.
We're going down here.
Alright.
Oh, you got the...
Oh, watch out.
You got this.
Okay.
I don't think you need to back up anymore.
There you go.
This way.
To the right.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh.
To the right.
Yep.
Yep, yep!
Okay, you made it!
Yummy!
Going great!
It's like a roller coaster, isn't it?
Wee!
It is like a roller coaster, yeah.
Now hard, hard left, hard left!
Hard left!
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh, jeez.
Oh.
I sure hope a bear doesn't show up.
Oh, Lord.
Another hard left.
You see me?
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
Don't face me, don't get run over.
Yeah, yeah, you're good, you're good.
Should I just go down now?
Yeah, just go down.
Just go down, just go down.
Okay.
It's scary, it's scary, it's scary, it's scary.
I see something down there.
You do, what do you see?
I see it with your special eyes.
I see it, I think, um, I see sexy ladies.
They're calling for me.
I must go to the void.
Wow, we might go.
Oh my gosh, we must go!
Wait, this part's pretty easy, though.
We'll chase after those sexy ladies.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
In, in, in!
Here we go.
Oh.
I'll catch up.
Are you in?
Nope.
You need to go to the left a tiny bit.
A tiny bit left.
There's a sexy babe at the top.
Yeah, sexy babe at the top.
There we go.
Nice.
Okay.
All right.
Sexy babe at the top.
It's our wives.
They're waiting for us.
at home.
Oh wait, what is this all here?
Yeah!
Oh, that's a lot of junk.
Yeah, there's a lot of junk here, for real.
Oh, wow.
What is all this?
Go get some of this stuff.
A ramp?
What is a ramp?
Oh, a winch pole.
That's kind of worrying.
Winch pole.
Why do we need all this stuff?
I'm kind of concerned.
Oh, we got some oil.
What's the oil for?
I thought epi pens were good idea.
Yeah.
Yeah, I picked up some motor oil before.
I don't know what it's for.
Sorry.
Attached.
Do we like run out of petrol at some point?
I don't know.
Oh wait.
Let's put that in.
Or sorry, run out of gas.
We got the gate.
Maybe we have to change our oil.
Maybe.
The engine's under the bed, apparently.
Let's have a look.
Is that what the blue is?
On the top?
Will that fix that?
The engine's here under the bed.
I don't know when we need to refill it, though.
Yeah, when, but what?
Tell us?
Whoa.
Here's an ear.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa.
It repairs the engine.
That's the red damage.
Now, huh?
Ah, the red damage.
Where's our ladder?
Oh, wait, we already have a wheel.
Yeah, I want to...
Oh, my bad.
Should I just leave one of these in here?
They're huge.
Right.
Yeah, I was trying to find this so I could...
There we go.
Disgusting.
Oh, you have to...
Wait, is that really what you have to do?
do.
There's all these wooden planks.
Oh, there's so many wooden planks.
Wait, we have more ramps and stuff.
We have more ramps.
Oh, there's so much scrap around here.
There's so much stuff.
I found another epi pan.
Yeah.
Use the things.
Beers.
What?
This is like... We're not the only people.
How many have died before that?
Yeah, that's what I'm gonna say.
We're not the only one stuck out here.
Yeah.
Boy, it's the lore in this game.
If there is some.
All right.
I like this.
placement of the ramp oh yeah yeah it's good we we have to
drive over that oh my god what we have to just drive through
these rocks how's that gonna work oh what where the heck are
we meant to drive in here i don't know i think you follow
the obstacle yeah you like follow the rocks around this way
like the path continues here so you have to make a full turn
oh drop we have to drive over them rocks i guess that's why
we're being given ramps where does the path continue i can't
even i wish there were pings in this turn like over here i
know i wish we'd ping look here uh i'm jumping i don't see
you oh there i see you yeah um it's like this way oh yeah so
we basically are making a big ue around now yeah oh my god
whoa that's so hard oh there's more scrap over here nice
nice nice i don't go too far yeah i might meet a bear i know
i have a beef with that guy i need to settle yeah we need to
show him who's boss One beef.
One beef.
I have one beef to serve.
I have exactly one beef patty with the bear.
Oh wait, people are saying use the winch.
It would be so easy if we did.
Oh really?
Which we, you have all these winch poles.
We have all these winch poles.
We just can we like take a shortcut and winch ourselves up?
I think so.
No.
We just placed the pole like right here and then we put the
winch.
and then we pull ourselves over get it pull we wench pull
ourselves over oh no who do okay wait where am I I just see
rocks everywhere guys where's the van oh there you are okay
okay I'm putting this down I'm putting these poles down or
the planks down Okay So that we can get you over the big
rocks Do we want to set up some ramps as well At the bits
that are a bit tricky?
Oh, yeah, yeah, that would be good Where do you think would
be nice?
Maybe here?
You can't really position the ramp, though It doesn't turn
the way that you want to Try to put it down Is it tricky?
To be honest, it's quite small.
Will it even be helpful?
Oh, Phoebe.exe.
Hello?
Robo Phoebe is back.
Am I wrong, Phoebe again?
Yeah.
I'm Phoebe.exe.
It works so well.
Oh, here we go.
I'm going to try.
Oh, we're off.
Oh.
Oh
Close Wait up Oh, yeah
Oh Oh
I'll load up on beer in case I need to Get one out ready I
think we need to push you guys Yeah, can I get a beer?
Yeah, of course you can I'm right here Thank you.
Oh, that works.
I got it.
I'll come push you.
Yeah.
Chug-a-chug-a, babies.
I've got something to do now.
Yeah!
Oh!
I'm coming.
Uh...
Now wrench us.
Huh?
Okay, I'm gonna...
Um...
I'm gonna use the wrench control.
No, I think you should...
I think you should drive forward.
That is 45 degrees.
Yeah, I think you should drive forward.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is that
all right?
Yeah.
Oh, wait a second.
Do I need to push?
That is an angle, isn't it?
I think if we get underneath the...
I think we can get under the tires and push.
Oh, no.
and push okay let me have that bit oh my god what an angle
okay i'm gonna also i don't think so i don't think so vicky
i might wait here oh oh
the road yeah we skipped so much of it we did oh my god
shortcut oh whoa big brain guys we're pros we are pros do we
need anything here oh which poles are one time used by the
way oh they are oh you're Right!
Okay, well, it was good in this situation.
It worked.
Did we take the other ones and put them in the van or?
I don't think so.
I think we should do that.
Should I go grab them?
Yeah, I'll help too.
They're over here.
They're in the van.
They're right here.
There's one here.
There's one here still.
Oh, there's one?
Yeah, I got it.
Okay.
The ramps are also in the van.
I think we might need the ramps for the...
Do you think the ramps are one-time use or no?
No, I think I put them down.
as far as i know okay but they're they're blooming massive
do we need them they're well annoying i think we can use it
here though like i think it would be good for this part
because okay right i'll try it yeah i think so let's try it
i mean to be honest either way i just want them out of the
van they're taking up far too much space okay i'm gonna drop
it i can't even get to my beers wait how do i i'm gonna drop
it Does that even do anything?
It's really hard to position them.
I know.
How's that one?
It's really bad.
I'm gonna get out and see where exactly we're gonna go.
I don't think they stack.
I mean, you could try.
Okay, I see where we're supposed to go.
Yeah?
This way.
Hold on.
You've seen the vision.
I see your vision.
I'm visioning your vision.
I'm envisioning.
I actually...
actually think we should go over here i'm gonna eat some
crisps yeah translators know chips do it yes just using the
right word there proud proud of you crisps because chips is
like you know you want fish and chips in it you know slip
your chips and some ketchup and that what flavor oh my god i
just chugged my cigarette phoebe i'm sorry that was oh my
gosh it got all over me oh you can chug a cigarette yeah
when you're done with it oh sorry oh my god sorry
no you're bad okay i don't know why or when it does that but
oh maybe it could in not think okay does so i will let's see
vicky does fries mean anything in british i mean we know
what you mean but it's yeah fries and chips fries is just
the american way of saying chips in it and it yeah in it in
it what what kind of what kind of uh crisps you have in any
women.
They're nice.
They're veggie crisps.
Yeah.
That's so good.
Where are we sideways?
Oh, I see where you're going.
Oh, ah.
The vision.
I thought we were going up.
I do think that's where we're supposed to go.
Because there's a whole path down that way.
Oh, I thought we were going up where the wench was.
No, honey?
Yeah, I thought so, too.
Wait, do we want to put down some planks, though?
Let me put some planks.
It could be this way, though.
Let me have a look what's up this way.
Uh-huh.
All right, don't go until I'm done with all the planks.
Okay.
I think this is the way, actually, because this is the way
to the construction site thing.
Yeah, I think that is probably the way.
Then we'll have to move the cranes somehow.
Just ain't that the way?
The, wait, the crane?
The cranes, yeah.
Wait, there's cranes.
The cranes.
Do I mean big... I could mean beautiful birds.
Yeah, that's what I think you means.
Yeah.
I've always wanted to go see them in Hokkaido.
Ooh.
Do you think this is gonna work like this?
I feel good.
Yeah.
Yeah, why not?
Like that?
I'm just a little worried about this guy as well.
But we might be okay this way.
If you try going to the right, a bit yeah I believe guilty
oh you are genius oh you are so genius yeah I'm an engineer
women in STEM oh my gosh guys women in STEM yeah good job
good job good job yeah baby I'm getting in closing that door
let's on the road baby how'd you do that I don't know I
don't brew the wind disagreed yeah so there's like I think
we will do that right now.
I'm gonna make a windshield for us.
Oh, that's why I went through.
Okay, go ahead.
Are you?
Oh, did I?
Whoa.
That was my head.
Yeah, that was my head.
Oh, damn.
Your head does not need fixing.
You are genius.
Wait, can't we just go around?
There's a gas station up ahead too.
Can't we just go?
There's like a cliff on the, that's right in front of us.
Why do we need to go down?
Ah, soca, soca, what to keep going this way?
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, where are we going?
Yeah, yeah, we don't even need to go down the cranes.
Yeah, you don't need to go to the cranes, no?
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I think so, right?
Okay.
Right?
Up there.
To the right, right?
Up there?
Yeah, to the right, to the right.
Okay.
To the right, to the right.
To the right, yeah.
Sorry, did I say left?
I meant right.
Take it back now, y'all.
I always wondered I was like what is the right foot right
foot left stop what the what is that as a kid I was always
like I don't understand it's like your right foot but your
left toe oh nice nice oh yeah yeah yeah nice nice nice
what's this up here got like a little tower watch tower.
Actually, while you do this, I'm going to go see if there's
any supplies in the area with the... Oh, good idea.
I'll park here.
Nice idea.
Because there might be some stuff down here.
With the cranes.
Hopefully, by stuff, we mean not bad.
Not bad.
There's not going to be a bear.
There wouldn't be a bear here.
Yeah, bears.
Nah.
I definitely see stuff i'm gonna go up these stairs and see
what's up here so much scrap so much scrap give me give me
give me so much scrap so where are you guys did one of you
go down to the cranes yeah i'm at the cranes yeah i'm
getting all the scrap baby or the ramp i went up there was
nothing oh baby's going up the the big thing yeah i'm coming
to see you to the dodgy looking oh the rock why are we on
the rock um what's wrong oh oh thank goodness Phoebe did you
just drop something down there yeah I did oh there was
something up there dying good there's there's stuff I think
I see I think I see a computer barn up here computer barn
computer barn wait where are you I think she went the tower
look oh okay okay oh i see the stuffy dropped nice stuff
what was that stuff did you just finish your cigarette oh
that was a snake i think that might have been a snake just
keep running just keep running something poison me oh you'll
get over it okay oh hi hi hi look at the internet It's
computer boy.
Oh my god!
It looks exactly the same.
Also, I have this cassette called Sir Fluffington III.
And I'm excited to listen to it.
Wait, there's so many burgers here.
I can eat snakes again.
Oh, there is one.
I'm not afraid of you.
Yeah, shut up, bro.
Nuggets!
Oh yes, we could have nuggets in a can.
Oh yeah!
Canned nuggets.
That's technology guaranteed.
too far winch controller oh i hear it oh there's a snake up
here be careful yeah where is he is it that guy he's just
outside over here look there he is wait who died somebody
rip who died oh that's a revive station okay oh that's cute
rip there's so much here winch control power oh there's if
you lose all your things guys you want to see me chug some
nuggets yeah yeah
yo yo how are you whoa liquid nuggets delicious i don't even
know how you did that wow what was that i can hear the snake
snake shut up i heard like a crinkling yeah same that for?
Yeah?
Can we, like, make stuff?
There's so many wheels.
This is, like, the perfect repair station.
Holy cow.
How do we even get the RV up here, though?
Um, I think we have to go around, probably.
Right?
Uh, right?
I mean, if we really tried to see if we could get it up this
route.
I was thinking that I did not want to entertain the idea.
We may have limits, but maybe we can push past those limits.
Oh, look, a beer station and burgers.
Yeah.
There's so much.
Oops, ouch.
I'm gonna put in the fucking team, the third cassette.
I'm gonna bring it to the RVM.
Yeah, yeah.
Yay.
Let me see.
I'm gonna look at the map real quick and see it.
It feels important.
Okay.
If maybe.
I don't...
Eh?
I don't know.
Where are you, Snakey?
I can hear you.
The ugly baller by Archibald.
What?
It was a dewy morning on Sunspark Isle when all the ballers
came out to play.
All the ballers!
We've all been over-slept.
They were missing out on all the fun.
Again?
They quickly shook off their drowsiness and raced out into
the field.
Raced out into the field.
They cried out in excitement to their fellow ballers.
But instead of welcoming Fluffington the third they all
jeered at them oh don't have no idea why the others were
mocking them it was only yesterday that they were all
playing together after all distraught friedon the third
trotted over to a nearby lake to drink some water oh no as
fluffington the third lent over they caught a glimpse of
their reflection oh yeah they noticed once again that they
don't look like the others.
Fluffington the third always found it strange that they were
always fluffier and a different color to the other ballers.
Not to mention that they had four legs instead of two and no
hands.
Oh Fluffington.
They felt the gentle headpats of their Wrangler companion
which as always melted away all of Fluffington the third's
sad feelings.
That's so sweet.
Hey yeah Fluffington the third began the Wrangler.
Wait it is just the British part and all the Americans.
It's definitely get you.
Rangloon began shearing the wool off Fluffington.
Fluffington III wondered why the Rangloon never did this to
the other boulders, but it always felt nice to Fluffington
III.
Okay, Fluffington III.
Go play with the others now.
I feel like I'm missing some context here.
Yeah, really?
Fluffington III returned to the other boulders.
At first, they looked at Fluffington III curiously, unsure
of where their wiry fur went.
But then, they kicked Fluffington III of all, and they all
began happily playing together again the moral of the story
cut your hair leave what oh okay where are you guys cut your
hair everybody cut your hair i have so much motor oil you
guys a cinema roll um wait can you move your hair over here
vicky uh move it towards me yeah yeah i can I can cut off, I
can cut off a little cinnamon roll for you guys.
No, like go.
Actually, look your head over towards me.
Okay.
Yeah.
No, not in the game.
In real...
Which way?
Other way, other way.
Other way.
And see which way?
Okay, just a little closer a little closer okay hang on that
was so close the cinnamon roll come on come on just give me
a little taste more come on give me a little taste here you
go here you go how's it taste
dozo is it tasty yeah it was delicious no problem no problem
glad you liked it
Yeah, I do.
You're kind of far, but I was thinking of trying some of
Mint Ongale.
Oh, yeah.
Let me know how that tastes.
Yeah, uh, uh, is my close?
I think...
I... I can't...
I may be too short for this.
I don't know.
But it looks so yummy.
spaghetti maybe maybe mince maybe mince ponytail is
spaghetti here hold on i'm not gonna be able to hear you
guys for like two seconds one second oh yeah no worries yeah
all right team we're gonna adjust there we go phoebe there
phoebe you should be able to eat it now oh everybody's like
on top of me it feels like they're in my lap
of doing this oh is she eating it is she eating it are you
eating it i think so it's delicious whatever it is thank you
wow wow oh
yeah toothpaste let's go toothpaste mint fresh minty
freshness yeah anytime you need to refresh your they just
give me a little oh yeah I'm gonna replace clean machine
just eating mince hair from now on there you go how useful
from here guys I don't know where to go yeah I don't know
Eva I think we might have to winch up we might have to winch
up we might have to winch up this thing yeah we got a winch
up baby oh my god what about the what up here oh yeah yeah
we got a winch up jesus really disgusting oh yeah i see it i
see it yeah i got the winch pole we got this winch it up i
mean once we get up here right it's pretty clear where we go
and we've got a repair station everything so i think it must
i think it must be where do i attach this to though
Can I just place it anywhere?
Wait, where should I place it?
Yeah, I don't know.
Like, all the way up the top?
It can only go so far, though, right?
Yeah, right.
Should we have kept another one?
We have a couple more.
Is there any more?
Yeah, we have more.
Oh, we do?
Yeah, we have a few more.
We can just do multiple wenching.
Oh.
Okay.
That was close.
That was terrifying.
Ah, I see.
We've got a couple here.
Now, I don't know.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
And there's some more in the car as well.
Cool, cool, cool.
Okay, I'm gonna put this...
Extend the winch.
Walk up with the winch.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
See how far it goes.
Okay.
This far.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
Then should I put it, like, right here?
Yeah, that might be good for the first time.
okay cool winch are up baby should i do it wait let's get
the other way i'm gonna have another winch pull in hand you
can also be the controller person let me know you want me to
do something where do we go
i'm ready to turn if means b i think we need to go up here
right yeah this way this way maybe turning a little bit to
the left right actually this is fine i think the right
actually is safer yeah the right oh yeah i just said that i
couldn't actually see what you were doing
okay that's lovely guys that's lovely Okay.
That was surprising me alright.
If I take this, if I take this winch, can you park it?
How do I park it?
Uh, P. How do I park?
Okay, press P. Oh god, I'm falling.
I'm falling.
I'm falling!
Oh!
um um here this is here we have we have another winch pole
oh right here you guys meant shift into p you meant the
other p not no there's no it wasn't a shift it was a press a
button p i i thought i did press the button oh oh i'm sorry
guys but you down should i should i just should i just get
out you know i feel like i shouldn't be on the wheel wait oh
thank you oh there we go oh there we go i feel like it's
just not meant for me guys you know wait why can't i reach
it oh wait wait wait wait wait grab it okay and that was
attached to you oh oh oh and then okay okay okay and then we
can oh my god what's happening why is What is happening?
Go!
Be free!
Why is it?
Why is it acting like this?
I just reset it.
Yeah, it...
Okay.
I got it!
There!
Okay.
Nice.
And the controller is over here.
Yeah, you want some extra pushing I can do some pushing if
that would help
Okay, okay Okay Looking good looking good The butt of the RV
we need someone to be driving it We do need someone to be
driving I'm getting in I'm getting in wait, I think no It's
like 90 degree angle so I kind of am so stuck a little bit.
Oh, wait.
Wait, I'm in!
I'm in!
You're in, you're in?
Okay, good.
Good.
Nice, nice, nice.
Nice, nice.
What's happening?
Wow!
Bouncing!
The winch is in the way.
I'm going to reset the winch and you just drive forward,
okay?
Okay!
Nice.
We dropped some winch poles, so I brought them back.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, thank you, thank you.
right here oh that's not what i meant to do so now we're
back to oh my oh my gosh it's going it's going okay i'm
pushing i'm pushing oh it's still going backwards okay it's
fine okay i parked nice suit um okay who would like the
controller here uh guys you like to be the guardian of the
controller yeah what do i do with the controller okay
release pull reverse toggle front drop Pull to throw.
Okay, yep.
Pull.
Oh.
You gotta reset it, I think.
Reset.
There you go.
I got you.
Pull, right?
I'm pulling!
Yes.
Okay, cool.
Oh!
Oh, it's fine, it's fine, just keep going straight, keep
going straight.
Just keep pulling, okay?
Yep, yep.
Cool, cool, cool, cool.
Nice.
You're good, you're good.
Now we can park.
Is it in park?
Now I stop, right?
It's in park.
Is it?
Is it in park?
Oh,
it is in park.
Yeah.
It did not look like it.
Okay!
Still does not look like it.
Alright, we're pulling!
Pulling!
We're pulling for Wifus and Gacha.
Here we go.
No, we're not.
Okay, here we go.
Hey, look, let me get...
Okay.
Oh, hang on.
Okay, Phoebe needs to get in the van.
Okay, are we ready?
We're pulling?
Okay, we're pulling.
Here we go.
We're ready.
What's it stuck on?
Some angles.
I don't really know.
What's it stuck on?
The ground?
Nothing.
Oh.
going slowly going it's going here's the angle there we go
i'm pushing yeah yeah nice nice lovely lovely keep going
keep going keep going keep going
lovely lovely
I'm okay!
Hold on, let me reset the winch.
Okay, you're good.
Okay.
Now come towards me.
Oh, thank God.
Yeah!
We better!
Yay!
Wait, can we make some burgers so we can heal?
Yes.
I'm firing up the grill.
Almost all my bones are broken.
And there's some burger patties here.
Woohoo!
Wait, how do I drop?
How do I put it on?
Oh, just like that.
He's rescued.
So do burgers out in the open encourage bears?
Or I mean, let's face that one.
No, no.
Yeah, I'm sure it's fine.
Oh.
Oh, they're so cute.
I'm getting that.
Oh, can I have Johnny?
Oh.
You can have Johnny.
I hope this doesn't give me the shits.
Oh, yeah.
Lovely, lovely.
Very good.
That actually helps so much in my health.
Mmm, delicious.
It is so cute when they pop.
I know.
Eee!
Oh, it's another Johnny!
Johnny!
Oh, you got two buns and me.
Two buns and me.
It turned into two buns and me.
Would anyone like two buns and me?
My health isn't so bad right now, so if anybody wants it.
I have a tiny broken bone.
I've probably just broken like my finger or something.
I think I'm fine.
Oh, then I will have two buns in me.
Yeah, yeah, have it, have it.
What's the lotion do?
I'm going to try it.
Yeah, do it.
What does it do?
They make you silky smooth?
I don't know.
How do I look?
You look lovely.
Flawless skin.
Really?
Mm-mm.
I'm going to repair some of this, at least.
But also, you already looked lovely, so...
I'm not quite sure.
Stop it, stop it, stop it.
Oh, we do have a bunch of scrap metal, so we may as well.
Yeah, I was looking at her thing.
It wasn't looking so hot.
Oh, sorry.
Excuse me.
Sorry, sorry.
Just got a big old head in the way, you know.
Yeah.
My big, big brain, my big air is taking up a lot of space.
I'm going to drive it into the garage.
Nice idea.
Yeah, I think we can go for some other repairs.
what that machine is yeah good plan wait i sure hope i
didn't use all of this scrap for the repairs to be free
watch out watch out watch out i sure hope no oh hopefully
not
good good run over the snakes oh yeah snake yeah oh did you
actually i might have guys do you mind if i while we were
pairing do you mind if i really quickly idle meeting oh not
there don't okay not there i don't know idle meeting no idle
there oh oh oh oh okay quick brb okay wait how do we oh
there we go i got the welder nice nice what does it do
though it's not like question Slippatronic?
Where would it repair?
Wow!
The undercarriage.
Oh!
Oh my god!
It works so well!
Our...
Our bus is...
Busin!
Oh, sorry.
It's busin' Yeah!
Place and activate power poles.
For real, for real.
Not quite sure.
But that was before.
Put it inside.
There's an upstairs!
Wait, really?
Oh wait, that's our bus.
I keep calling it computer board.
Well, it's not really an upstairs, but I've made it an
upstairs.
Ah.
It's called a roof.
Shut up!
My chat is hating.
I mean, what is the room that's not in upstairs?
Yeah!
Wait, I'm checking out the lake a little?
Okay.
I think we could scale that big rock.
Oh.
Oh!
Do you see it?
This one right here?
Wait, where are you?
Oh, there you are.
I think it's time to climb the rock.
Uh, pull me.
Come on, Phoebe.
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's do it!
Let's do it.
Have you been...
Do you go mountain or like rock climbing or anything?
No, but my sister did.
She...
Did she like it?
I know a lot of people getting into...
Whoa.
Oh, I thought there were bugs.
I got scared.
Yubi!
Oh, so much.
Wait, I got the nugget cam.
Hey, yo.
Alright, I'm gonna chug these nugs.
Are you gonna chug the nugs?
Yeah, I'm gonna chug these nugs.
Oh, it's horrible.
I'll tell you did it with the sig in your mouth.
Which glasses you think looks better on me?
These?
Or these?
Oh my gosh.
I already have a special pair.
The other ones?
These ones?
Well, you have them then.
You have them.
Okay, well, look how cute they are.
Look at some quality street.
Welcome back!
We're at the rock!
Vicky!
Come to the rock!
Oh, the big rock!
The big rock?
Yeah, the big rock.
Yeah, the fancy rock.
Come here.
Two, two, a minute then.
I will come there.
The interestingly shaped rock.
Yes, I'm coming.
Yes.
I'm going up.
Okay.
We're going up, up, up, up, up in our moment.
Our moment.
You can climb this thing?
What?
I don't know.
I was gonna try.
It feels like you can.
I don't think so.
To an extent, maybe.
I mean, don't hurt to try, though.
Wait, who got poison?
like poisoned yeah who's poisoned right now oh i'm a little
bit poisoned oh sorry i used it on my
where are you oh there you are someone's left a song on the
floor
how every everything hurts oh my god i like how we just
swing our arms around it's so cute me too it's very cute
just swinging just swinging along all right well i guess
that's all there is over here do we want to keep going yeah
yeah how are we on the map like how long till we get to the
the uh destination oh i have no idea we'll check the map
when we get yeah let's check the map and see i think we're
probably just around the corner Definitely.
And we've been going for like a long time.
Yeah, yeah, it's like right there.
It's also my munching by the way.
That's okay.
It's okay.
If I had something to munch it, I'd also be munching on it.
Yeah, also don't forget to grab these beers here.
Whoa, yeah.
Oh, I grabbed a coin.
Wait, that works too?
I think I need that.
Wait, did they break?
That'd be awesome.
I don't know.
Oh, what they're using their stuff in?
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe so.
We could try.
Or we could try running them over.
I don't know if that does anything.
Oh, ow!
The poem is just over that mountain, apparently.
Wait, we have more antidote inside.
I know we do.
Oh, the van's looking lovely.
Oh, no smoking.
Yeah, don't listen to that.
Wait, what language is that?
I don't know.
Monkey, where are we meant to be in this game?
my wonder all right how close are we Phoebe um we've gone
quite far however it looks like the
I love Swedish the little the little heckin gnomes that you
can buy in the shop in Sweden we go buy gnomes is there
shops around here okay there's gnomes in the game probably I
hope so.
Exit to about E5.
Okay.
Um, campsite.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Phoebe, it looks like you're twerking right now.
I'm not quite, like...
What is it?
There you slept at it.
Oh, sorry.
So like, where is the exit?
I don't know.
But where is the exit?
Chat, it's just over the hill.
Were they lying?
You can see how far we've come.
Just over the hill.
You're kind of twerking a little bit.
too much is really hard to see the map because you're just
working it's really hard to concentrate on the map yeah
you're just twerking it so i like can't see the map damn
okay let me put this down
oh gosh we're always twerking it though i know let's see
whoa zoomed in um
where oh what's the verdict chat did the chat light to us
well there's i feel like the next gas station isn't that far
where is this the route is that the 85 where we need to go
why are there no signs on this map.
We bought the cheap map.
It doesn't have any information on it.
It's a cheap escape.
Spend all our money on beer.
Oh my gosh.
I don't know.
Red circle.
There is no red circle.
There's literally no...
This?
Just that?
That's...
So we have no idea where we need to go except the circle?
Whoa, guys.
Come see this.
Come see the magic of my floating beer in the toilet it's my
new magic show what floating beer can you see it no can you
see my beer floating no you're holding it you're holding it
look in the mirror look in the mirror look she's so drunk
you guys you're still holding it in the mirror she's so god
you guys okay on mine i guys it was magic no i'm sure i'm
sure i'm sure i'm glad you're having fun i'm glad it was
floating guys and whatever she's smoking is just it's not
what we're having no it's different i don't even know how to
take this cigarette out of my mouth to be honest i think
it's just consistently in there
I guess we go up the path.
I guess so.
Up the hill.
Oh my.
Yeah, to the...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop!
Where I am.
I will lead you the way.
Yeah, why are we still going backwards?
Oh, up that way.
Yeah, that way, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, come here.
Are you inside?
50.
Oh, no, you're not.
I'll get in.
Come here.
Exit took 65.
67?
What?
No!
67?
Wherever you...
No!
It's two versus one.
You guys came from that one!
You'll become one of the last eventually.
I know you won't.
I'm like, 37!
Wait, why am I dead?
Good.
Karma.
Oh my god.
Where are you?
Oh, it's the person.
He's going to seriously knock me out of the van for that.
I watched you, I watched you like fly out, but I don't.
What happened?
Where are you?
I don't know.
In a bush.
Wait, wait, we can go back to the revive thing.
We can go to the revive.
We can't.
Oh, you're so, oh my gosh.
How did you get all the way over here?
I don't know.
With the beer either.
Look!
Look at her!
Never, you guys, six, seven, not even ones.
Yeah, I guess so.
This is what happens when you six, seven, unresponsibly.
Unresponsibly.
Good lesson to learn, chat.
Revive station.
Revive friend.
They put me in there.
They won't let me.
Wait, is there like a...
Am I still alive?
Oh, there's like a dead dead maybe?
No, no?
Oh.
So...
Okay, remember there's a snake, guys.
Alright, put her in by the snake.
Good idea.
Well, you're gonna kill me!
Yeah, and then we revive you.
Okay.
Cool, where's the snake?
Oh, oh, thank you!
Oh my god!
Her body just...
Are you just gonna have fun killing me now?
Why?
Why can't I revive you?
This is so cruel.
Oh!
Where is the snake?
Yeah.
So different.
What a thrill.
Very different.
With darkness and silence.
Throw her off the cliff.
I mean, you might as well, guys.
If we're near a revive state, you might as well see how far
you can take this.
Yeah.
Just throw me.
Wait, is there like a dead dead state?
Yeah, there has to be if we can't revive her right now.
Chuck me.
Oh.
From...
Sayonara.
If you want to do it.
Yeah, I can do it.
Just do it.
Just throw me off.
Shadow the hedgehog.
Is there anything Shadow would say before you like chuck
someone over?
I mean, no, it's more this is guys.
This is me falling off space colony arc.
Okay, do it.
Do it.
Sayonara.
Oh, Vicky!
Maria!
Why?
She bows.
How?
You're still alive.
Oh my gosh.
Well, I mean, how is Shadow alive?
You know, many questions.
You should have, you should have gone, you should have gone,
Maria.
I did, you know what I hear me?
I shouted Maria as I fell.
Oh, I didn't hear it.
Anyway, that didn't really work.
So if we don't just go on EpiPen, it'll probably easier.
Yeah, just revive or just revive.
If you can't revive for some reason, I can't use it.
Oh, you can't.
I don't know.
Maybe the, oh, I mean, don't worry.
Oh, no, wait.
Oh, wait.
Do we have it on us or is it like an item that you have to
pick up?
No, we have it on us.
Yeah, for some reason here.
Like, it only gives me the option to pick her up.
Hold on.
Let's try.
Maybe she's dead dead now.
Where's the snake?
I'm scared.
Yeah, guys, there's a snake.
Careful.
I think he's only up towards the thing.
I hear it, but I don't know where it is.
I don't know.
I haven't seen him around this area.
I think you're fine.
Okay.
Thanks guys for taking my body all the way back to the van.
Yeah, of course.
Appreciate it.
What happened again?
Oh yeah, I said it's a 7 and the van kicked me out.
I was like, why did I die?
Okay.
Let's see.
Let me see if I can revive her.
Okay.
Oh no, it doesn't.
It only lets me pick her up, yeah.
Let's take her to the grave.
We said they got three syringes.
syringes they're just different ones
oh wait why am i getting pulled the part of the snake if you
want are you carrying me i was carrying you carrying vicky
oh you can do that i was not even what oh let me slap your
bum a little bit more oh sorry oh oh oh that's gonna kill me
okay this again bro you could let this you could let the
snakes
yeah i don't know we could restart because we're at the
checkpoint we could i'm scared though what if it like puts
the van all the way back down to the bottom or something no
just just take me in the van just put me on the bed it'll be
fine look guys let's be honest i'm not really helping so
just put me on the bed you are you're our moral support yeah
it'll be okay it'll be all right do you why says we have
three should be at the repair station yeah i don't know if i
trust it though what if it sends the van all the way back
down it would be so sad i think it probably would but we'll
find an epi pen we'll find one there's got to be one
somewhere soon we have three epi pens though it says we have
three yeah you want to be i just like died too much yeah
just put me on the bed it's fine oh my god
maybe but still doesn't let you do it no
strange it's so strange it isn't a gas station you're good
to checkpoint okay apparently it is fine to checkpoint if
you guys want to do that um okay i'm gonna click restart
from checkpoint then i mean to be fair maybe it glitched
because i i genuinely don't have any idea how i died yeah it
just heated me out of the van it did i watched it happened
yeah i just watched okay i'm resetting in three two one are
you okay let's see last checkpoint two hours ago don't say
that chat don't say that it's scary okay wait there's stuff
we gotta grab though there's still things over here yes yes
um i have to repair the the car again dang it oh yeah okay
hold on all right we got a little bit of stuff to do was
there any um stuff that we need to go grab i'll go grab the
bees oh yeah maybe by the rock oh yeah and if you can make
the um oh yeah by the rock yeah we have stuff over there too
oh by the weird shape rock yeah yeah by the weird shape okay
i'll go i'll go i'll go check it out the other way yeah and
if you don't if you want oh if you want to make the
hamburgers again I'm good oh nice idea or I can do that I'll
make burgers for everybody to heal oh lovely all right crap
metal and don't crap metal Already holding iron.
All right.
Paddy.
Dinner is served, everybody.
Oh, whoops.
Woo-hoo!
Don't mind the paddy that was in the dirt.
That's a flavor.
Oh, I've got some drinkable nuggets as well.
Two buns and meat.
Aw, no Johnny burger.
Okay.
okay do we need the engine oil i could only hold one thing i
feel like it's better to bring the antidote right yeah
probably probably okay we have a lot of oil in the car i
think got it you got this baby went totally the wrong way oh
i think so oh okay i'm gonna put the car out of reverse okay
uh put that there there we go oh thanks for the burgers
lovely oh i don't actually need one oh okay maybe i will
bring it back to the van yeah we have supplies they might
fly out but they might not oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah how do I attach this where's our ladder hunter can't
use the cabinet by this cabinet where's our ladder is our
ladder gone I think so no but it should be fully repaired
right no there's like one little tiny bit no the little red
oh maybe it's the ladder then let's see definitely grab some
beers what's the red yeah yeah okay ladder is back what's
the Ouch, ouch, ouch.
I'm sorry.
Oh, oh.
I'm so sorry.
You guys okay?
There's an attempted murder over here.
Oh.
Detective Vicky is on the case.
Okay.
So what happened?
Nothing.
Who murdered who?
Phoebe, I just saw you drop that hammer, very suspiciously.
Was it you?
It's for healing.
Hold on.
I'm dead literally right here.
Wait, hold on.
Is there any of you?
What?
You're dead?
Oh.
Minto.
What is she saying from the grieve?
A ghost though.
So how does that work?
Oh.
No.
All right.
Are we good to go then?
I guess for.
Oh wait.
There's a beer still down here.
I think if we want to.
Yeah.
I was just.
grabbing them yeah i'm in the van put them one at a time
oh there's also burgers the drinks to things yeah there's
more burgers because i had the liquid nuggets oh see be go
eat they taste delicious do you have do you have health i my
health is like perfectly fine like oh okay i'm bringing the
burgers anyway yeah bring them bring them with us then it'd
be nice if i could take more than one at a time but i know i
didn't realize the coasters on the table were probably
needed yeah they're for the drink so that you don't they
don't fly out yeah that's so useful uh is there anywhere we
can put the but there's nowhere to put the burgers is there
just go on the floor i think just on the floor i want a
burger so bad right now oh me too i had such a nice one the
other day oh Oh, what kind of board?
It was like, there was like avocado in it.
It was like avocado teriyaki sauce.
Oh.
And then like really nice patty and an egg.
I pat an egg in it as well.
Oh.
It wasn't Wendy's, was it?
No, it wasn't Wendy's.
Although they do have Wendy's here.
Yeah.
They have like the teriyaki burger.
I mean, that sounds good.
I actually like Wendy's.
Me too.
They have interesting stuff, like baked potatoes.
You know?
What are you trying to say, Vicky?
Yeah, they've got baked potatoes at Wendy's.
Yeah, that's what I always get.
At Wendy's.
Wait, you two?
No, I don't know.
Sorry.
My apologies.
No, no, never apologize.
She did it this time while the car was not moving.
Oh, I think that's used.
I don't think we can use that again.
Oh, oh, it's like Dundas.
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, it's done, done.
Oh, you're right.
But that's it.
Dun, dun, dun.
Dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun, dun.
Dun,
dun, dun.
Alright.
Let's go!
I think we're good to leave.
Should we take this repair hammer with us?
I think that's probably a good shout.
Oh, probably.
Just take all the tools, actually.
Yeah, why not?
Why not?
They've got a place where they can go anyway.
I think there was one more winch controller.
Because ours is gone, actually.
So I don't know where it is.
Wait, is it?
Yeah.
Gone?
Yeah, if I hadn't grabbed that one, it wouldn't have...
I don't know where it is.
Sorry.
Was I in control of it last?
That's probably the mistake that we all made.
I thought I saw one down here.
Maybe I'm crazy.
All right.
another one too.
I thought I saw one.
Well, we have the winch controller in here.
Is this the one that was on the floor?
Yeah, that's the one that was in the garage.
Yeah.
Okay.
So I think we're good then.
At least we have one.
Okie dokie.
Alright.
Yippee!
Woohoo!
Y'all good to go?
I will be seated.
Take us home, Phoebe.
Take me home.
Oh wait, I forgot to turn on the engine.
There we go.
Take me home.
To the place.
I belong!
Follow me!
West Virginia!
Okay, it's fine.
We're fine.
I'll make it.
Oh my god.
On tree road.
I think I gotta reverse first.
Road.
Oh my god!
Don't do it, Phoebe!
Don't do it!
No!
God!
Oh god!
No, please!
Oh, you're like going...
Mento!
Mento, where are you?
Mento, I'm here to eat the guy, you!
Okay, are you in?
Are you in?
I'm in!
Oh, uh, yeah.
Wait, uh, wait, um...
Wait, oh, I'm in.
I'm in.
Oh, okay.
Okay!
Yeah!
Ooh!
To the left.
To the right.
Oh my god.
Not to the...
To keep going right and then to the left.
To the left.
Oh, hard left.
Hard left.
I'm so scared.
Harder.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're so good at driving.
You say that, but what happened there?
Don't worry, I can repair.
Let's put the windshield.
Don't worry about it.
All right, keep going.
Keep going.
Don't worry, don't worry.
All fixed, all fixed, guys.
All fixed.
It's another one of these.
Oh!
Oh.
Wait, keep going?
What do you...
Just keep going?
Maybe just floor it.
Ooh.
Oh, there's like a tiny little ram.
Wait, hold on.
I'll get out and I'll direct you.
Ah!
Thank you.
Whoa!
What is it?
What happened?
It's a bear.
I think it might be a bear.
Do we have any spray?
Oh, my God.
Run over.
Floor it.
Oh.
He's
bumping on the lake, look.
Oh, wait, why did he jump?
Wait, you guys, he just jumped.
He jumped?
What?
No, the bear can't jump.
Oh, no, no, no.
He's run away.
You run away.
What is, what is the physics on the bear right now?
He's trying so hard.
He's killed the cliff!
Wait, he's gone, he's gone!
He just disappeared into the cliff.
Oh my god.
What just happened?
That went really well.
Guys, the snake is like right next to our stuff.
I mean, look, we just took on an Isakai bear.
I don't think we need to be afraid of the snake.
Oh.
Lady, go after me!
You two.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, it really reaches from all the way over there.
It died.
Oh my god!
Why is it- Oh!
Oh!
Thanks!
Sorry!
Oh, Vicky, it's okay!
He's like, inconveniently position snake.
He's like right underneath her.
It's very annoying.
It's so annoying.
Can that snake can that snake just calm down?
Like it ain't a thrill anymore.
It's just a boar, bro.
I'm gonna go to the rock and get the stuff from over there.
Oh my gosh.
It's such an... It's so annoying that we have to recollect
everything each time.
Yeah.
Knows you're a snake eater, Mintel.
No!
Knows about your interests.
Yeah.
He's like, I'm just trying to return the favor.
What else we need to get?
Should I make burgers?
Yes, please.
I mean, I'm poisoned, so I could definitely do with a
burger.
Burger.
Okay.
Will beer help the poison?
I don't know.
Actually, it'll help the feeling.
Um, I don't need a burger anymore.
Oh, I got some bear spray.
Oh, okay.
Bear spray!
That is what we need.
Hey, yo!
Oh, that is what we need.
Wait, there's a ton of stuff over here.
Oh, yeah?
Yeah, I'm gonna come try to help you carry stuff.
Yeah, I think if you want to grab the grill, I think we'll
be good.
I don't know what we need the lotion for yet.
Hmm.
wait where oh but by the rock yeah i'm at the rock oh okay
burgers don't appear to help at all with poison without
coffee no they don't coffee help with poison are you super
poisoned um like half my bar oh shoot i should have given
you the antidote oh no it's all right don't worry i'll be
fine living life she's tanking it she's tanking it yeah all
right i'll bring bring some bring some burgers for for
everybody
licky's burgers coming right up what if i do this here i'm
gonna i'm gonna eat this grill so you could bring why is the
snake under the van by the way i know he's annoying wait i
think we need to repair our tire he scares me every time how
do i repair the wheels We need a little power drill.
Oh!
There's power drills in the van.
Yeah, yeah, I'm grabbing it.
Without hopefully getting eaten alive.
Watch out.
That guy's like right there.
Oh, stop.
Snakey.
Oh my god.
Is that you?
Yeah.
Oh my god.
me try and scare it away as a piece of your own medicine oh
thanks okay so we got a grill bear spray and i'll just grab
the lotion and that should be everything from the box do we
need the lotion i i don't know i can only just hear phoebe
but it's like it's it's nice i wish i always had phoebe in
the back of my mind saying stuff oh no i can i can hear
phoebe just i think she's very far away so i can just hear
her like faintly in the background Yeah, I'm back.
Welcome back.
Get those beers on the drink mats.
Beers on the Barbie.
On the Barbie.
I mean the burgers.
I meant burgers, sorry.
Burgers on the Barbie.
Surf and turf.
The beers could also be on the Barbie if we want.
The beers are also on the Barbie.
On the Barbie.
Yeah.
No, I feel about that.
Oh, so close.
Were you chucking that coffee just for fun or do you want me
to put it in the bag?
No, I was gonna grab it.
I was gonna...
Oh, I was chucking things to put in the bag.
Okay.
Oh, but they're rolling back down the hill.
Oh, I just realized my mistake.
I've been chucking things at the hill and they've been
rolling back down.
I got it.
I've been putting them in.
It's okay.
Oh.
Okay.
Do we want to take this lotion?
Still don't really know what the lotion does, but sure.
Okay.
All right, guys.
I think we're back to business.
Yay!
This guy.
Did someone just get bitten?
No.
Okay.
Nice.
All right.
Yeah, bear spray is important.
Do we want the bear spray on the floor or can we put it in
the cupboard?
Oh, we can put it in the cupboard.
We can, okay.
Cool.
Yeah, then it won't just fall out.
I don't think we can put burgers in there.
Wait, I'm going to put this upstairs.
This big guy.
Wait, can I even...
Wait, did we have to repair the...
Oh, yeah, we have to repair...
The ladder again.
How long does it go for fire or burn damage?
Wait, we can get damaged by fire?
When's that going to happen?
Oh, yeah, when's that going to happen?
Oh, geez.
What side is the ladder?
I hope it's not the other side because that's where the
snake is.
That is where the snake is.
Snake is...
Oh my god.
Snake is just...
Snake's twerking as well, look.
I think it's on this side, no?
Look at that.
Oh.
Ow!
The snake is under the van twerking.
Oh, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
This happened the last time, too.
Here you go.
Thank you.
Is there another murder investigation that I need...
Detective Vicky needs to get involved in?
Perhaps.
She's alive.
I mean, wait, no, she's not alive.
Excuse me, baby!
That was an admission of guilt!
I am butterfingers.
If you accidentally kill a person, what is that called?
Homicide!
Death is dead!
Yeah, Phoebe.
Oh, wait.
That snake is so loud.
Are we good to go then?
Did someone get bit?
I think so.
Yeah, I think we're good.
Okay.
Awesome.
I will be seated.
Let's go, baby.
Let's go.
Woo-hoo!
We'll make it this time.
I am quite scared for that bridge.
Well, as long as there's not a bear, I think we can make, we
can figure it out.
Oh, shall I?
I'm going to get the bear spray in my hand right now, just
in case.
Just in case.
But that's a windshield?
That was the roof shield, but that's okay.
The door also is not looking great.
Convenient exit.
In this case, it would be meat slaughter.
Let's try just to bore it.
Is that what we're going to do?
Bear?
Is there a bear?
I use the best profile.
Did this, ohhhh.
There's a second bear spray.
I think there's a second one somewhere.
There's a second one.
Oh, that's good.
Is there?
I don't know.
I don't think there is.
Oh, really?
I don't think so.
Oh.
Wait, check all the cabinets.
Open every cabinet.
Oh.
Oh yeah, Vanta Do.
Wait, Vicky, don't you need that?
I am going to repair the door in the meantime.
And maybe some windows and things.
We can get him with the ball.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, with the ball.
Oh, no.
See?
Is it normal scrap mail?
Huh?
Oh, did I fix it?
I already know.
No, you were hitting my head.
That's why.
Oh, so sorry.
Ow, ow, ow.
Fuck.
Manslaughter.
Ouch, ow, ow.
She's gone mad.
Use high gear, I'm begging you.
We gotta build up to high gear, right?
Probably.
Yeah, right?
That's how much we know about it.
You go to one and then the two and then the three.
So maybe I should back up and try to build up to that.
Don't say it.
Seven and eight.
And a six.
Oh, I'm so scared.
I'm so freaking scared.
And a six and a seven.
Then the back, I'm so sure.
you die and the game crashes and it deletes our save okay
okay you can do this baby you can do this you can do this so
what did we do last time that didn't work we were not fast
enough yeah oh you need to be fast Maybe if you go for
someone said skip second gear.
Is that true?
Anybody who drives manual.
I don't know whether to believe them or not.
I don't know.
I know you guys there's somebody in chat that can drive
manual.
Tell us.
Say one to three.
Yeah, see one to three.
You gotta build up.
Oh, they said yes, you can skip.
You can, you can.
You can?
Okay.
Go, baby, go!
No!
Yes!
Okay, skipping a three did not work there.
No, I think you gotta really build it up.
I think you gotta do three at the very last second.
Okay.
Gotta rev out one before going three, apparently.
Okay, okay.
Maybe once you get to the top of the hill, go to three.
Yeah, on the hill, stay at one.
Once you're over the hill, go to three.
Three when going downhill.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
Oh no.
Did it work?
Oh!
Wait, is it?
Um, it's really not...
It's...
Try, go to four!
Go to four!
I'm on four, I'm on four!
I think...
Okay, back it up, back it up, yeah.
Yeah, back it up, back it up, back it up.
Back it up, back it up, back it up.
Okay, I'm there.
Minto, you seem to be outside the windshield.
Are you okay?
Oh, how did I...
Wait, but we have a windshield.
How did that happen?
I don't know.
This happened to be several times.
I think that's how you randomly die.
Hold on.
Get back in here.
How did I do that?
I think that's the main way of random death in this game.
Okay, I can't get back in, so just...
Just go.
I'm coming.
I'll pick you up.
Pick me up.
Oh, yeah, thank you.
Yeah.
There you go.
Okay, thank you.
All right.
I also saw one, two, four.
So maybe go one and then...
the hill at the top go two and then go to four it's because
if you go one to three there might not be enough time for
the three to kick in all right now one two okay now four
four I think you can't oh oh yeah baby now back to one back
to one back to one Yeah!
Yeah!
Woo!
Oh my god!
Oh, thank goodness.
Incredible.
Holy cow.
MVP.
MVP's MVP.
Go.
Woo!
Incredible.
What is that?
What is what?
What is that in the road?
I hope it's not a bear.
Oh, oh, wait.
Okay, we got to build another bridge.
It's scarier than a bear.
We got to build another bridge.
Okay, now on.
I see.
Okay.
Can you keep doing it?
Can we just like...
Oh, oh, I see.
There is other wood.
Okay, like.
Are there other...
Oh!
A bear!
Watch out!
Oh god!
Back in the van!
Go back in the van!
Oh no!
Oh, he looked at me and I scared him away.
Oh come on, why me?
Oh he's aggroed on you.
It's because you're the MVP!
Okay guys, I know, I'll scare the bear.
Yeah, okay, so I'll scare the bear off and then we drive.
I think Phoebe just did that.
Phoebe, we need you!
Phoebe, I should be the prey!
Phoebe, come back!
Oh, but he's aggroed on me!
No, no, no, no, just, just...
I'll get him to aggro me, I'll get to aggro me!
Just keep running, Phoebe!
We'll, we'll get the car, we'll get it all mixed, we'll get
it all set up!
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
Are you guys okay?
Did you run off?
Uh, I think he's on me.
I'm following him.
Oh!
I'm inside the bear.
Inside the bear.
Can I drive?
Just go, guys.
I'm just driving the bear.
No, don't drive.
No, no.
You can't.
Don't drive.
No.
Okay, don't drive.
Okay.
No, don't drive.
No.
Don't do that.
Okay, the bear's gone.
Wait, really?
He just left?
Yippee!
No, he's not gone.
Well, she, Vicky punched him.
I don't know where he is, though.
I think I might have absorbed the bear because I, like, I,
like, fused with the bear's model and then it's gone.
So I I think maybe we're safe.
Either way, I think it's obsessed with me to go.
Do you still hear him or something?
No.
Yeah, I still hear him, but I can't see him.
So I think I, like, fused with him.
Oh, cool.
I think it was like Dragon Ball or something.
Okay.
Okay, I did the best I could do.
Thank you.
Okay, be in a safe place.
really weird guys.
I can hear the bear, but it's not here.
But don't worry.
I think I've glitched the game, so just go.
Jesus.
Oh, I think the game, or not the game, I think the, you can
still hear the bear.
I think the tires are wider than I thought they would be.
Back it up, back it up.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, wait.
Oh, hold on.
One second.
Oh, Adam.
Oh, there we go.
Maybe it's okay.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, I messed up.
Wait.
There we go.
Try now.
Okay.
Give it a try.
Yep, yep.
I can't hear the bear anymore.
I think it's safe for me to come back.
Okay.
Good.
I miss you so much.
Oh, go to your left a little.
Your left.
Go right.
Okay, in reverse.
No, no.
No.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You going.
You need a push.
You got it.
All right.
Now stop.
Yeah, stop completely.
I'm going to have a beer in hand in case you need a push in.
Oh, thank you.
Okay.
Gonna light one up as well.
Now I make another one.
Oh, you got it?
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
You can go in and get it.
I've been in there before.
I do.
Oh, watch out.
Oh, dang it.
Oh.
Can you break the other one off too?
Or I got it.
I'll grab it.
Oh, nice, nice.
Yeah, we needed one.
Oh, I can't pick it up because I'm holding bear.
Hang on.
Okay, hold on.
Okay.
I got this.
Do I need this one or should I do that somewhere else?
There's another.
Yeah, there's another platform.
There we go.
I don't know.
is wide enough maybe oh wait you wait you might not this
last one is kind of crazy don't understand how this works
doesn't go over far enough yeah maybe you don't need one for
this yeah maybe you have to do the shift again shift gear
again yeah maybe yeah it doesn't go over I don't think so
just give it a whirl Okay.
Yay!
There's everywhere.
Yeah, I just grabbed one.
If I close the door to lower possible burger spillage.
We also lost a grill.
There we go, we lost our grill, but I got it.
We're okay.
How does everything, like, drop so easily?
Even with the doors closed.
Yeah, I know.
I guess it eats through the windows, we do whoa oh you're
fixing oh someone's drilling oh damn wow whoa let's go drill
sugoi sugoising okay oh oh oh sorry i let me grab you i'm
gonna use that sugoising okay we go wait that's so good with
me driving or did anybody else like want to have a turn for
no keep going i like watching okay Maybe I really don't
think I should drive.
No, I don't think so either.
You know, I do believe in you.
But maybe this is not the best environment to practice in.
This is not the best environment for practice.
This is scary.
I don't like this.
Oh, it was scary.
Oh, I'm not even going to put any energy into that.
Yumi!
Yeah!
Woo-hoo!
Oh, oh, a little too hard.
A little too hard, yeah.
It is all right.
Oh, okay.
Left?
Yeah.
Yeah, left.
Oh, there you go.
Left.
Oh, come on.
What's going on?
Oh, uh.
What is going on?
Oh, we are on something.
Something is stuck on us.
There you go.
I'm gonna have a beer and push anything.
I don't know why sometimes I can push it.
Sometimes I can't.
There you go.
Nice.
There we go.
Can you go again, Minto?
I'm coming.
Here.
Come here.
Oh.
What the?
Just drive.
Oh my god.
Wait, there's a bunch of...
The road is full of mees.
Wait, I want to get out and look.
Oh my god.
Are they alive?
Kill the mees.
Wait, I can pick them up.
Oh no.
Mees.
Oh, you're picking them up.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
Oh, we all have a mees.
Wait, can we like pretend?
to beat these guys?
There's... Wait, the gas station is right here!
The checkpoint!
The checkpoint is right here!
Let's go, go!
Wait, we can just pick these guys up and throw them.
Oh, you're back.
They're not even real.
Can we take one with us?
Yeah, I'll drive it over to them.
Yeah, roll one with us.
Oh, okay, good.
Okay, I'm just gonna hold it.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go!
Just go!
I'll go chase the bear again.
I'll become one with the bear.
Oh my god, he's right behind me.
Oh my god.
Oh he doesn't like the water.
He doesn't like the water.
I'm dead.
But don't worry, I'm distracting him.
He's still there.
Just go guys.
Do the thing.
Get the checkpoint.
We got the checkpoint, actually.
We got the checkpoint.
Nice.
Bye, bear.
See you later.
We got some more witch.
Holes.
Nice.
Oh, I'm alive.
Wait, how?
Why am I alive?
Oh, does someone revive me?
Oh, I revived you.
Oh, nice.
Thank you.
Got cold drinks in here.
Ah.
Welding.
There is a nugget can in there if anybody wants some.
Oh, sorry.
Ooh.
Anybody's hungry.
winch pole yeah that was us there more winch pole we got
austin lesson one uh a cassette tape
are you just smoking and all the same same way i feel so
dumb i thought that you had to press one two and three at
the same time so that's why i was wondering every time like
why sometimes it works sometimes it didn't it's just
different buttons now and then so you got those so one is
three is to throw it at people oh wait oh mine has been gone
i wonder where it is three is to throw yeah i'm gonna cause
a fire i'm gonna cause a fire right now oh my god this would
be the place to start a forest fire
oh Oh
Girl Chaka child and welcome to lesson one of the absolute
calm with Austin wait this is the awesome this is the calm
Hello Austin Oh
We're a sudden onset acute asthma attack.
Oh, I need to listen to this That was vital for the ancient
Anunnaki.
Me, they're talking about asthma.
Oh!
Now we have to go on a boat?
Is that what's going on?
I don't know.
Oh my god, the moose scared me.
Did I drop that moose?
I was trying to be a moose to scare the bear and then I got
attacked so.
Maybe.
Yeah, we probably have...
drown in this wow okay you ready wait what's happening what
this cranking is gonna do oh my god are you okay oh I see it
actually moves it I'm in the water
I'm coming all
right he's choking he's choking he's choking oh dear Austin,
Austin, I drew Buster.
Right.
Is he okay?
You in the van?
I'm in the van!
No.
Wait, so I just drive while it goes?
I don't understand though, it just keeps going back.
I know I have to hold E.
Yes, just keep driving it, yes.
Okay, all right.
Wait, I'm not, I'm not driving yet.
I'm not driving yet.
Okay.
Okay, hold on.
You ready?
Yep, I'm ready.
Okay.
Crank that.
Crank that soldier boy.
Okay, here we go.
Go, go, go, go, go.
Wait, what am I going?
To the right?
You...
I do, no.
Should I keep cranking?
Yeah, just keep cranking.
Um, okay.
Let me take a look outside, see.
I think I go to the right.
Now we can go to the right.
Oops.
Sorry.
Oh, okay.
Oh, oh.
Oh, my God.
I'm just gonna keep cranking.
Yeah, keep cranking it.
Keep cranking it.
It's not going backwards.
Okay.
We're good!
I made it!
Yay!
Can I stop cranking?
Yep, you can stop cranking.
Go!
Woohoo!
Minimal damage, minimal damage.
Yeah!
Yeah, it's pretty good there.
Maybe I'm just meant for that.
Cranking.
I was pretty good at that.
Yeah.
Pressing one button.
Okay, nice.
The queen of cranking.
I don't know.
I think that was you, Phoebe, because you were- you couldn't
stop earlier.
I remember.
Wait,
it was- you- I was diseased.
Dis-eeased?
What?
Yes.
I miss our moose.
I think we need to repair some windows up in here.
Yeah, same.
Maybe we should have taken him with us.
Let's see where we go next.
Oh.
Repair?
I think so.
Good, good, good.
What are you, what have you seen?
What's it look like?
Take a look.
I can't see anything.
I know, are we?
It's so terrible.
Here you go.
I've never seen the map.
Can I look?
Yeah.
Yes, yeah.
Thank you.
Look.
For now, I'm going to start going forward.
Okay, we're there.
Now, now?
Okay.
Are we meant to be...
Surely we're not heading into that black hole, right?
Oh, my gosh.
Do we have to jump across a ravine?
Oh, boy.
Okay.
All right, then.
Whoa, whoa.
I believe in us.
Yeah, be a leap.
It looks like that's going to be the case, probably.
I'm a bit scared.
No, to be fair, I believe in you guys to get done.
If it's me, I don't believe.
If it's one of you guys driving, you're going to be right.
How do you get over this?
I'm going to adjust that bridge for us.
Oh, okay.
Thank you.
Oh, no, the beers.
The beers are falling out like that.
Get that six pack.
Oops, I accidentally turned it off.
I didn't mean to do that.
Oh, it's just going on its own.
Yep, we made it.
We made it somehow.
Yeah.
Are you in?
Not yet.
Okay.
Wait, hold on.
Can I see the map real quick?
I am too short.
Can someone give me a lift?
Where did the map go?
Oh, there it is.
Don't worry, don't worry.
I see it.
Give me two seconds.
Yeah?
I'm giving them?
It won't let me...
Okay, drop the winch pole.
There's the map.
Oh, I see it.
It's combined into the floor.
Okay, there you go.
Thank you.
Oh, this is a little bit more windy than I expected.
Okay, you can go, Phoebe.
I'm going to go forward a little bit.
Yeah, go for it.
I'm looking at us on the road.
To the rock, to the ride.
Okay, wait, get on, bro.
Does anyone know what any other part of that song?
Wait, there's a fork.
There's a fork here.
What was that?
I have no idea.
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna explore a little?
Yeah, I'll go to the left.
Okay, I'll go to the right.
You're going to the right?
Okay, I'll go to the left.
I thought so.
this donkey singing is that on the road again okay are these
mines oh wait there's a mines there's a house here big red
button on the ground private property no trespassing yeah
but then i wouldn't get this sick hat yo that is a nice hat
oh my god look at these oh look at my god they're so a bear
there's so much stuff in here i kind of want this one
instead oh my god oh my god he's standing menacingly he's
just right there and epi pen's probably good oh wait he's
right there he's just he's he's right there he's right there
he's right there he's right there he's right there he's
right there oh hi oh there he is we can outrun him yeah it's
fine Don't worry, guys.
You guys go to the car.
I will run the other way.
Yeah?
Be ready?
Yeah.
Ready to go?
Are you sure?
Yeah.
Oh.
Be brave, Vicky.
Be brave.
You know, you're also kind of going to the car.
Are you okay, Vicky?
He's gone.
Oh, okay.
Oh, thank goodness.
Wow.
Wow, you're so good at fighting bears.
I know.
Oh, whoa.
What just happened to me?
I've got, you know, I may not be the brains, but I'm the
brawns.
Yeah.
I'll fight a bear.
Me versus bear.
I'll win every time.
You guys want to see what I think is a mine?
Oh, yeah, I want to go see it.
I think...
Yeah, where's that?
On this right side?
Oh.
I'll push it.
Ah!
Oh.
It...
Yeah?
Pinto.
Are you alive?
Hi!
Minto?
Where?
Oh, Minto!
You're alive!
Hi!
Yay!
It was, though!
Hi!
Yeah, we got rid of that pesky thing.
Oh, guys, that's what we used the cream for!
Yeah!
You guys got fire damage now, the explosion.
A little bit, yeah, a little bit.
Oh, wait, there's another one over here, be careful.
Look at the lift.
Wait, do we have that bouncy ball?
you're so right you're so big i think you threw it out of
the van like 30 minutes ago from what i remember okay but
what if we just like narrow hodo so we make a platform and
then narrow and then we then we lift it up so we make we
make a platform that's that's blooming difficult
It's really gonna work.
Bro, I don't think there's gonna...
Oh, lotion.
It's not long enough.
Are you guys pretty badly burned?
Like, half my health buff.
Oh, only a little bit burned.
I'm gonna eat some.
Go for it.
Eat it.
Oh, it, like, gets rid of so much.
It's pretty good.
There's, uh, one other lotion for someone.
I'm pretty sure you ain't eating that lotion, though.
Thank you.
It rubs the lotion on its skin.
Or else it gets dead.
Oh!
What?
Uh...
Who was that?
Baby?
Something in front of you just exploded.
Where are you guys?
I dropped the plank on it.
Oh, nice.
Oh, there's one right behind you too.
Can we pick these up?
No.
Who's...
Who's leaving mines in this peaceful...
Yeah, I don't know.
Oh.
Yeah.
What if I drop the one on this one too?
Okay, back up everybody.
Oh, nice, nice.
Okay, I'm backing up.
Nice!
Good!
Wait, I'm gonna do this one too.
I don't think...
I don't think the wooden planks are long enough.
Oh, maybe they are long enough.
Oh, I'm doing them the wrong way.
Okay, no, you're right.
You're right.
You're so right.
I was like, because I thought so too, I was like, there's no
way.
There's no way.
You're so right, Phoebe.
Oh, gosh.
Why didn't I think of doing them the other way?
I think we all know why, chat.
Here we go.
Oh, come on.
Okay.
Here we go.
This is not working, guys.
Oh, that's not quite.
Oh, oh, whoa.
I'm okay.
Did you explode something else?
You're okay?
okay i'm gonna get the car i think that's probably good to
get the get the van on and then someone i guess presses the
button right once the van is on sounds good wait was there
anything else in the house that we could get i'm gonna
double check a bear but other than that i think there was
most bear Would you like to come inside?
Oh, I would love that, Miss Phoebe.
Please give me one second.
I will daintily, um, curtsy up to the door.
Oh, oh dear.
Oh, oh, yeah.
Let me, let me grab you.
I see the, I see the, the, the hole.
The tip's fedora.
You don't, you don't wear enough fedora, Phoebe.
I need to clap my feet.
Hold on.
Can it, will this work?
Wait a second.
No.
Clap your feet.
Oh my god.
Oh no, don't do that.
Do you hear my feet clapping?
Hold on.
What?
Yeah!
Okay, why?
You don't just say milady and clap your feet?
What princess?
Princess.
Okay, I feel like such a princess now that you've clapped
your feet at me.
Oh, you are a Phoebe.
Okay, I'm in.
Are you in?
Yep, I'm in.
Yes.
Do you feel like a princess?
Princess you deserve to feel like a princess.
Aww, thanks, Phoebe.
Okay.
Well, your username is Headless He-made, so...
I can press the button if you like.
Yeah!
True.
Press the button, press the button!
I always feel like a princess when you clap your feet in me,
Phoebe.
I'll press it.
Wait, there's a thing, a beer right there too.
Wait, there's some beer.
I'll bring that too.
Are we all?
I got it.
I feel like I should at least be on the, like, get on the
platform once you go.
a little bit more forward.
A little bit more?
Forward, yeah.
I would.
If you can.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alright.
That's good.
Alright, I'm gonna press it.
Press!
Whoa.
Okay.
You wanna be on here?
You wanna get on?
I can't go up with you.
It's okay.
Don't worry.
I did not make it in time.
I will come around.
Alright.
And you're good.
You're good.
I'm coming here for you.
I'm running.
I'm coming, guys.
I'm coming.
Does it not go back down?
Do you want to go back down?
Well, I was going to say you could just take it.
We want to get you.
Yeah, you could come up with it.
Oh, don't worry.
I made my way up.
Wait, where'd you guys go?
Where are you guys?
We're up here.
Oh, okay.
That's a very tall.
Yeah.
Now, hold up.
I'm further up than you.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, okay, okay.
Watch out for mines.
Hello, hello.
But there's like a little house at the top here it seems.
Oh, there is, yeah.
Yeah.
Bear free.
And some meat patties.
Another ball.
Yes.
Wait, there's a ton of meat patties here.
Why?
I don't like the look of this.
Yeah, this is quite bad.
Oh, I think this might be the thing.
Yeah, this is the thing.
Oh, really?
Yeah, this is it.
Yes.
Oh, this is the thing.
Wait, I wouldn't!
I wouldn't!
I would stay there.
Yeah, I would stay there.
I'm parking here for now.
I also want to go.
Look at the pretty view.
I'm parkoring.
It's very nice.
I'm not parkoring.
You're parkoring?
Oh.
It's a little...
It's a very nice view.
Okay.
meat patty on its side how is it how are you doing yeah guys
look there's a water melon over there what does that do yeah
i know i want to try yeah it's parkour parkour water melon
okay i'm gonna grab some i didn't die oh dang it i over i
over missed a minute
oh my god Oh, there's a lot of scrap down here, too.
Oh, okay.
And bear spray.
Oh, oh, oh, you got this?
You got this?
Oh, oh, you're parkouring, you're parkouring.
Will she jump for the beef or the chicken?
Oh, oh, my God.
I'm, like, sweating.
The whole team depends on me getting this watermelon.
Oh, I believe.
consent there as well some some law that we'll never get
unless i can get there you can get it oh you're there you're
there oh what's that
that watermelon it might be a hat we can get it oh my god is
it oh my god that'd be amazing no way is it hot is it no way
What are we worth?
Oh, my.
What's on it?
What's on?
Am I going to get this piece of a moor?
Yeah, get it.
Is it worth it?
Okay.
What is it?
Oh, it's just nuggets.
It's just nuggets.
Actually, that could be very useful, though, to be fair.
That is pretty useful.
Already holding an item.
Drop my hat in the ravine.
We're getting pretty full on items.
We got a lot of stuff.
We got a lot of stuff so far.
Yeah.
nice okay now i'm only burnt awesome yay wow i can't believe
i did that i know jump queen got that warmelon out of it
jump queen is there anything on the other side i wonder
jumping back looks terrified yeah i'm a bit worried can i
get this lotion or am i gonna fall off give up on the do we
need lotion i think oh my god i don't know i can jump back
oh i think i've got jump over the other side yeah no you're
right you're so right i'm meant to be where min is yeah yeah
oh i think i think so
oh yay
is there anything over here watermelon hat intact oh my gosh
this map just makes me want to wander into the darkness yeah
yeah open world rv there yet i know oh
my god are we ready should we do some repairing before we do
this let's see it says that we've got some stuff to repair i
don't know yeah yeah you know maybe this is in case i want
to try it You wanna try it, you should try it.
Should I?
Try it.
We have, um...
I mean, I believe in you.
Yeah?
You wanna do it.
Okay, I wanna try.
Is there a, is there a bug or anyone?
No.
Why do you need...
Might make some.
Don't mind if I make some bugs?
Go for it.
Oh, please, Jill.
What's the blue one again?
No.
We need the welder for now.
Oh, the welder.
Wait, the blue is that...
Wait, uh...
Drop.
Oh, you can't drop here.
Can drop.
You can drop it.
Please.
Okay.
Get a good meal in us before we do that big jump, guys.
You know, we gotta make sure that we're feeling good.
Who wants burger?
Woohoo!
This is my last meal.
I quite like one.
Tasty burger.
yeah this is this is my last meal you guys are all why is
that burger okay that burger did cook on its side it's an
okay burger i'm glad i get to have one last meal with you
guys yeah one last meal together guys before we go into the
ravine glad it's with y'all you know but i believe we can do
this i don't want you to lose your hat i don't want you to
lose your hat no don't worry look to experience the
watermelon hat for a grand total of like a whole minute and
that is precious to me okay i'm gonna try the if we if we
don't make it we don't make it but who wants to go in the
front seat someone should go in the front seat okay i'm i'm
i'm consulting chat i think we should go to five but what's
what pattern one three five should we try that chat
consulting services
I think of 135.
Can I pee before this?
Of course you can.
Okay, do it.
I think that's important.
Okay, I'm going to pee.
Oh, I'm scared.
Okay.
It's important.
There's going to be lots of nervousness going into the
ravine, but we can do this.
Yeah.
All right.
I'll be right back.
You've got to put your foot on the gas and change when
you're at full pelt.
135 is good downhill.
Okay.
Man, I hope your bears show up.
Bears will be the least of our worries, guys.
Thank you.
I like how Minta's just staring at me right now.
She's staring at you while peeing.
I like just the expression of like, if she's peeing as well.
Oh my god, Phoebe, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Oh, thanks for the lucky, lucky spatchas, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
We feel the luck.
We feel it.
Thank you.
Okay.
What else can we do to prepare, Phoebe, do you think?
What else can we do to...
We could...
We could prepare some snake and ocelot fanfiction.
We should prepare our last words.
Oh, okay.
Slightly different vibes.
But yeah, yeah, either.
Either sounds good.
You know what?
I think that would motivate her.
It'll be like a carrot on a stick, you know?
Kind of think you need to put a carrot on a stick for a
minute.
What kind of carrots will put on the stick?
Hello, Minto.
Welcome back.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to put on my headphones.
One second.
Have some beers.
That's actually a good shot.
out maybe i could like push it right at the end oh yeah a
little liquid courage emergency beer osilot wait i'm gonna
i'm gonna have an emergency beer in my hand at the end
osilots at the end yeah yes snake and osilot fan fiction
waiting at the at the end of the ravine okay here we go guys
just for you it's peem i heard it's peem oh she got this Be
seated to everyone Oh my jesus Oh my god You got this you
got this you got this You can do it Yeah
Oh Guys this was a good time Honestly fun And you know maybe
i mean how are we how are we feeling how how long is left we
could like pick it up next time from the ravine again i
don't know what are we thinking i don't i have no idea i
mean re ravine i have no idea if it's anything like any of
the these other kinds of like endurance games we're probably
like not even halfway yeah people are saying it's a long
yeah we're less than halfway oh my god
Pickness was probably a good You know I'm kind of glad that
I Didn't stop Because the moose Just it restarted The moose
made it worth it It was all worth it It was the moose It was
the moose all along It's good Man I think it's telling us
not to abandon Our moose friend I think it's telling us to
take it with us I agree We need to take the moose with us
RV.
Is it inside?
Yeah, it can.
You can't put it down, so I have to...
I can't hold anything else if we take the moves with us,
basically.
Oh, you can't put it down.
No.
So I just have to just hold it the whole time.
Oh.
Did any of you guys when the game got reloaded in just
hear...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
From the moves.
Yeah, yeah.
It was.
It was the best.
It was so good.
It can go on the roof.
Are you going to tag it to the roof?
Oh, really?
Wait, hang on.
Wait, did we lose all our stuff?
Choked a minute.
No, we're good.
Do I still have my hat?
Probably not, right?
No.
Oh, it's all right.
I had the brief experience of it.
Okay.
It won't let me climb up the top with the moose, though.
It's not letting me climb.
Oh, no, it is.
Okay, it is.
I'm just not very good at it.
You got this?
I've got this.
We're putting that moose on the top.
You know how, like, pirate ships have, like, mermaid statues
at the front?
There are some moose.
it across again with the moose yes that's so good let's go
yeah amazing amazing incredible it needs a name chat any
suggestion yeah what's it what should his name be everybody
oh wait who who just put that up uh i don't know but i i'm
gonna i'm gonna vote what do you mean who just put that pull
up absence of moose who put that up
absence of moose very well may not have been him but i'm
gonna blame steiner for it
Why don't you tell us to bring the moose?
Yeah, we'll be naming the moose.
I think Absence of Moose is winning.
You want the name to be Absence of Moose?
You want the moose to be called Absence of Moose?
Um, Abbey for sure.
Abbey?
Abbey.
Abbey, full name, Absence of Moose, the moose.
Oh, damn.
Nobody would guess.
that's like psychological what is yeah wow okay abby nice to
meet you abby you'll be coming with us next time yeah we'll
definitely make it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this is so
fun it was so
sides hurt i know same my face my cheeks hurt from smiling
yeah thank you guys thank you guys thank everybody for
watching thanks everybody um thank you both for playing yeah
thank you guys what streams you guys got coming up this week
anything uh exciting to share with with the uh the peeps Oh,
I just saw what the name of the pole is.
The mean what the pole says.
Yeah, it's who's to blame for what we're being.
Hey, Abby's to blame apparently for not being there for her.
Wait, so we just named the moose.
I love it.
For the name of the moose?
Yeah.
He's hot.
It's not exactly got much of a ring to it, has it?
Absence of Moose.
Minto.
La mao.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Well good.
Everybody agreed that it was without our moose good luck
charm.
Yeah!
Wasn't me or Minto?
I thought it was like some...
I thought like...
I thought naming the moose absence of moose was like some
philosophical like...
Absence of Moose Yeah, because it's a Moose right there but
Wow
Biographical of the Moose titled Absence Absence of Moose By
Absence Of Moose
Wow, thank you so much Thank you so
much oh wow that was something guys something i'm feeling
true good
i think we should drink one last cold one together everybody
come on yeah i think Yeah, grab one.
Whatever you have.
You know, if it's a rye bean, oh, I quick have a wench pot.
Please don't drink that, please.
All right.
That's very sweet.
Thank you so much.
Thank you for the kind of you.
Thank you.
Bring it up.
All right, guys.
We poured one out for you guys.
Yeah.
Let's go.
Yeah, pour one out for you guys.
I'm going to chug it.
Woo-hoo.
Chug it.
Kampai, everybody.
Kampai.
Bye!
Yes!
Woohoo!
Ka-ca-ca-ca-ca-ca!
What's the Densetsu!
Bye!